in a world driven by data the ability to
manage and manipulate databases is a
crucial skill for Professionals in
various Fields now whether you are a
software developer a data analyst or a
business intelligence specialist
understanding the basics of SQL
databases is the foundation for becoming
a database expert SQL importance lies in
its ability to efficiently handle large
volumes of data perform complex queries
ensure data integrity and enable
effective data management now to
understand the significance of SQL let's
consider a scenario where you work for
an e-commerce Company the company stores
vast amounts of customer data including
orders products customer information
much more interrelational database now
as part of your role you need to analyze
sales data to identify the top selling
products for a specific month without
SQL you would need to manually shift
through the entire data set which would
be time consuming and prone to errors
however with SQL you can write a query
to extract the required information
quickly and more accurately on that note
hello everyone welcome to Simply learn
today we will take you through SQL
database Basics course where you will
learn the foundations of database and
the need for SQL in this training we
will export the fundamental concepts of
SQL equipping you with the skills needed
to navigate to the vast and
interconnected world of relational
databases but before you begin if you're
new to the channel and haven't
subscribed already consider hitting
subscribed to stay updated with all the
latest Technologies and don't forget to
hit that Bell icon to never miss an
update from us throughout this training
we'll cover a wide range of topics to
ensure you grasp the essentials of SQL
starting with a quick introduction to
databases now SQL training usually
begins with an introduction to databases
emphasizing their purpose and importance
in organizing structured data now you
will learn about tables rows columns
keys and relationships between tables
furthermore you will also export
different database management systems
and their SQL implementations and then
we head to learning SQL fundamentals now
this section covers the basics of sqls
into during the syntax and common data
types Learners will learn how to create
and manage databases tables and indexes
you will gain a solid understanding of
SQL statements such as select insert
update and delete as well as logical
operators for data filtering the
training then delves into the select
statement which is used to retrieve data
from one or more tables Learners will
learn how to construct queries with
Clauses such as where order by Group by
and having Clauses you'll also export
the concept of joints to combine data
from multiple tables as well so as I
progress we'll go through filtering and
sorting data next this module focuses on
techniques to filter and sort data with
SQL queries Additionally you will learn
how to apply aggregate functions like
count sum average to analyze data next
we'll go through modifying data concept
so in this segment you learn how to
modify data within a database using SQL
statements you will gain insights into
inserting new records into tables
updating existing data and deleting the
records the training also emphasizes
transaction management and importance of
maintaining data Integrity during data
modification as well and finally you
will understand the importance of data
integrity and how to enforce it using
constraints using keys such as primary
key foreign key and other unique
constraints Additionally you will go
through different types of joints
including inner join left join right
join and much more which is used with
nested queries to retrieve data from
multiple tables so all these topics
provide a solid foundation for you to
working with SQL and relational
databases with that having said so if
you want to upskill yourself in the
field of data analytics and become
proficient in SQL and database
management then our postgraduate program
in data analytics in partnership with
Purdue University and in collaboration
with IBM can help you with that this
course features master classes and
follows an applied learning model
designed with real life projects and
business case studies which will help
you boost your career so what are you
waiting for enroll now and take
advantage of this amazing opportunity
you can find the course Link in the
description box below so without any
further Ado let's get started over to
our training experts and I welcome you
all to this interesting session on
introduction to SQL
learning SQL isn't an uphill task
because unlike other programming
languages SQL is quite simple and uses
common English words in its usage
even a non-technical professional with
no prior experience in programming can
easily learn and understand it according
to a survey by stack Overflow in 2020
SQL ranked as the third most used
programming language
also every 9 out of 10 companies in the
world uses SQL isn't that interesting
well before we get started if you're new
to the channel and want to learn more
about latest Technologies consider
getting subscribed to our Channel simply
code and hit that Bell icon to never
miss an update from us
so without any further Ado let us dive
straight into today's topic on
introduction to SQL
firstly let us discuss the agenda for
today's session I'll start this tutorial
by understanding what a database is and
look at some popular databases next
we'll understand the need for databases
after that we look at the evolution of
SQL and how it grew over the years
then we'll discuss what exactly is SQL
followed by some of its unique features
next we'll go to the working of SQL
types of SQL commands
towards the end we'll discuss the
advantages and disadvantages of SQL
and finally we'll see some applications
of SQL in real life
what is a database data in today's world
plays a vital role in our everyday lives
be it your work related data in your
laptop your bank account details or even
your Gmail password so it's necessary to
store this data safely and in an
organized way that's where database
comes into picture which holds and
manages the data
a database can be defined as a
collection of information or processed
data that can be stored and accessed
whenever needed for example we can use a
database to store the complete details
of an employee working in an
organization
the primary goal of a database is to
store and retrieve information
efficiently
popular databases some popular open
source and commercially available
databases are MySQL Oracle database
Microsoft SQL server mongodb and post
clear SQL
why we need a database now that we've
understood what a database is let's
understand the use of database and the
need for it
database came into existence in the
early 1970s but all the data was stored
in computer files before that as the
technology kept advancing it became
difficult for computers to handle when
the number of files increased and the
volume of data grew
the so-called traditional file system
was no longer able to store and retrieve
data efficiently
let us now see some of the limitations
and drawbacks caused by traditional file
system
data redundancy and inconsistency
redundancy means when the same data is
getting duplicated and repeated in
different locations this leads to access
and unwanted storage which eventually
results in inconsistency where the data
in separate files do not match with each
other
data isolation data is isolated because
it is scattered in various files in
different locations and the files may be
in different formats as well at any
point writing your application programs
to retrieve the appropriate data becomes
difficult as the files are separated
from each other
limited data access file storage systems
usually do not have access for multiple
users this means multiple users at
different places cannot access the data
simultaneously it becomes difficult to
access important data if multiple users
are searching at the same time
security and integrity issues data
stored in files can easily be accessed
and tampered so it's essential to
prevent unauthorized users access to
hold the data's integrity
in order to limit all these drawbacks we
use a database that is controlled by a
database management system
let us now look at the history of SQL
SQL was developed by IBM in the year
1970. Dr Cod boys and Donald Chamberlain
proposed a paper on usage of relational
database management they came up with
SQL which can be used to perform
operations on data stored in the
databases
SQL was made publicly available and was
accepted for the use of relational
database in year 1974.
initially the language was known as
Structured English query language
pronounced as SQL which was later
changed into SQL in the year 1978.
the American national standards
Institute ANSI and other International
organizations have standardized SQL as a
language for database communication in
the year 1986.
no companies use a different version of
SQL nowadays the latest version of it
was released in 2019 by Microsoft
what is SQL SQL is defined as a
structured query languages
it allows the user to manage and
manipulate the database
so you might have got a doubt in your
head that we have discussed databases
earlier and why we are discussing SQL
now well you got it right both database
and SQL are interconnected to each other
SQL allows you to perform operations
like insert update modify and delete in
the database
in a nutshell SQL is used to communicate
with the database systems to retrieve
the information
features of SQL
SQL is one of the most demanding skills
nowadays where they ever increasing
amount of data SQL serves as a powerful
tool to provide insights to businesses
while handling databases
SQL is used to define the overall schema
that is the complete structure of the
database by managing and manipulating
the data accordingly and retrieving the
information whenever required by the
user
SQL also allows flexibility as it uses
simple English words in its queries like
create delete
Etc
SQL can handle large amounts of Records
stored in databases with utmost
efficiency
let us now see how SQL Works a typical
SQL database engine includes a storage
engine which is a database server and a
query processor within the SQL engine
to understand simply let us take an
example
suppose Jon is an HR Manager working in
an organization he wants the information
of all the employees who have joined
last year
John writes an SQL query in his laptop
to retrieve the data in order to execute
the query it must interact with
relational database management system
within the database server
and the request should be a valid query
before the SQL engine can process it
the SQL engine then writes to and
retrieves data from the database server
both database server and SQL engine work
hand in hand together to process the
required data the system process the SQL
request and sends it to web server
to access the information via SQL
database and if the information is found
in the tables the database server sends
the information back to the user
in this way John can retrieve the
information from the database using SQL
types of SQL commands SQL commands give
instructions to database to perform
specific actions to retrieve the data
SQL commands are broadly classified into
four types the first one is data
definition language or ddl ddl allows
the user to define the table and change
its overall structure
commands that are used in ddlr create it
is used to create a new table
alter it is used to modify the existing
table by adding unique attributes drop
it is used to delete the whole table and
the data stored in it truncate it is
used to delete the rows in a table
the next one is data manipulation
language or DML DML is used to access
and manipulate data in tables commands
that are used in dmlr select it is used
to extract data from the tables update
it is used to update a value in the
existing table delete unlike the drop
command the delete command is used to
delete a specific Row in the table
insert it is used to insert a new value
into the table
the next one is data control language or
DCL
DCL is responsible for maintaining the
security which gives control access and
permissions to the database commands
that come under DCL are Grant it is used
to Grant permission to user to access
the database revoked it is used to
cancel or take back the earlier granted
permission
the last one is transaction control
language or TCL
TCL has three commands namely commit it
is used to permanently save the
transaction
rollback it is used to restore the
transaction that is not saved
save point it is used to hold a
transaction temporarily it can be rolled
back to its previous state at any point
let us now look at some of the
advantages of SQL
one of the main advantage of SQL is that
it provides access to data stored in
database with its high speed and fast
acquiry processing quickly and
efficiently
SQL is open source that means it is
publicly available and can be accessed
from the internet it is also
straightforward to implement as well
SQL also provides the user to have
multiple views of their content stored
in the database
SQL is efficient in retrieving vast
amount of data using simple queries
and also it is portable as well which
means you can perform all these
operations at your home or your
workplace through your laptops and PCs
disadvantages of SQL there are two sites
to every coin and similarly SQL also has
few advantages which are not that
significant
initially one may find it challenging to
work with SQL due to its complex
interface
since it's a platform based languages
most of the commercially available SQL
servers costs are relatively higher
SQL is constantly working on these
massive amounts of data stored in the
databases and hence maintenance costs
are also high as well
let us now look at some of the
applications in real life of SQL SQL is
widely used in various sectors nowadays
some of them are education schools and
universities use SQL and databases to
store and retrieve information about
their students
faculty and staff
Healthcare hospitals and other medical
centers use SQL to store the details of
the patients without any hassle it also
helps in maintaining all the documents
and bills as well
retail and e-commerce with its vast
presence in the market retail and
e-commerce companies store their
customers data to improve their shopping
experiences by providing special offers
which will in turn help their businesses
to grow
is one of the significant components of
banking sector as well Bank store the
account details of customers and the
transactions done on day-to-day basis in
the database
Finance Finance is another massive area
where SQL queries are used regularly in
managing the assets Revenue details
shares of the companies Etc faster
execution and retrieval of data are key
for all the businesses to make
strategies and derive insights from it
companies using SQL
SQL is used extensively every day by
some big Tech gen companies like Google
Microsoft Oracle Amazon
Facebook
Etc even small companies and startups
heavily rely on SQL to make better
decisions and provide Solutions and
service to customers
with that we have come to the end of the
session on introduction to SQL by now
you must have got some idea of what SQL
is over the years SQL has evolved and is
widely used nowadays worldwide it is one
of the most efficient database languages
out there it can perform various
operations on the database to retrieve
the data instantly
SQL is very simple to understand and
easy to learn as well as all the
commands and queries are written using
English words
unlike other programming languages SQL
requires almost no coding it does not
require thousands of lines of code the
syntax is also user friendly and easy to
implement welcome to another interesting
video tutorial on how to install MySQL
server on your Windows system
so in this session uh we'll go to the
complete installation process of MySQL
workbench as well as MySQL shell which
is basically a command line used to
create tables with the help of a SQL
language
so without any further delay let's get
started
but before we begin make sure you have a
good internet connection so that at any
point you won't find any issue or
difficulty with the installation process
so let's go ahead and start with the
installation firstly go to Google and
type MySQL
you'll find MySQL official website page
on the search result click on that
once you reach the official website page
you'll find download section click on
that
now scroll down a bit and you'll find
MySQL Community GPL downloads click on
that link
now you'll find various options for
download such as various repositories
MySQL shell MySQL workbench Etc but
since we are installing it for the first
time on our Windows system and we are
only concerned with the MySQL workbench
and shell I will go with mySQL installer
for Windows click on that link
now you'll find two options for download
uh the first one is Windows 86 32-bit
MSI installer it is showing here 32-bit
but it will work for a 62-bit systems as
well so don't worry and you can choose
either of the two and I'm going with the
first one click on download
now you'll find this page where you will
have login and sign up uh for the Oracle
account for time being just ignore that
and click on no thanks to start my
download
save it on your system
once it's downloaded open the file
give all the necessary permissions
now you will find a setup page where
you'll have different options such as
developer server client full and custom
I will choose custom because we want
MySQL workbench and MySQL shell so click
on next
now we have to select the products which
we want to install in our system uh you
can find MySQL server click on that and
expand it you'll find MySQL server 8.0
click on that you'll find the latest
version of it click on that and select
the arrow and send it to the other side
now scroll down a bit and you'll find
applications click on that
you can see MySQL workbench
expand it and you'll find the latest
version of it as well click on that and
click on the add-on send it to the other
side scroll down a bit and you'll find
MySQL shell as well click on that expand
it select the latest version
click the arrow and send it to the other
side now we are good to go and click on
next
now it will ask for the path where you
want to install all these files we are
saving this on our C drive
just check all the necessary parts and
click on next
now all the three products are ready to
download click on execute
again uh now depending upon your
internet speed this may take a while so
don't worry just sit back and wait for
it to get downloaded
you can see all the three are
successfully downloaded uh click on next
now we need to install all the three
products click on execute
so you can do the installation process
simultaneously with me or just take a
note of it and perform it later as well
on your PCS and laptop this might take a
while so we'll wait for it to get
installed
as you can see all the three of them are
successfully installed click on next
click on next again
I'll find the server configuration type
you'll find different port number and
protocol Port just leave as it is
because it is set by default by the
system click on next
I will have the authentication method
you'll be provided with two options I
will choose the recommended one which is
given by the system
click on next again
now we have to set a root password so by
the way guys the root is basically the a
default user which will have who will
have the access to all the files and
programs so enter a password of your own
choice
and make sure you take a note of it
because I will have to use it at a later
stage and also by logging into the MySQL
server you will use the same password
so click on check
so as you can see there's a blue tick
mark which means it's verified so you
can go ahead click on next
now I'll find the windows service which
is the standard system account
choose that and click next
now you have to apply all the
configuration for the system files for
that just click on execute
and the system will automatically
configure itself
so this might take a while so we'll wait
for it to complete
as you can see the all the files are
successfully configured click on finish
click on next
so once you click on finish uh MySQL
workbench and MySQL will automatically
launch
so workbench and shella started in the
background uh as you can see there's a
local instant mysql80 click on that
now it will ask you to enter the
password which you've said earlier click
on that
so that's it guys we have successfully
installed MySQL workbench on our system
but before you get started there's
another little process that will with
that we are left behind with uh now you
have to connect all the files and
packages to the server before you start
working on the tables so for that we
need to locate where the where the MySQL
files are stored for that we'll go to
file manager
since we have saved the files on local
disk D local disk C click on C drive go
to program files
click on MySQL
open MySQL server 8.2
click on bin now these are all the files
and packages that you have to connect to
the server for that double click on
location path
copy the whole address
and open command prompt
on the command prompt you'll have to
type CD that is the current directory
and paste the address that you have
copied earlier and click enter
now type MySQL space my U root
minus P here minus U is the user which
is the root user which you have taken
minus p is the password click on enter
now it will ask you to enter the
password that you have set earlier type
the same
so if you find what you are seeing in my
system that is Oracle is registered
trademarkov Oracle Corporation and all
this thing that means you have
successfully downloaded and installed
all the files and packages into the
MySQL server and you are good to go and
start working on your tables right away
learning a new programming language and
its syntax can be quite difficult
sometimes whereas SQL syntax is very
simple to learn and easy to execute as
well more on that soon but before we get
started if you're new to the channel and
haven't subscribed yet make sure to
subscribe to our Channel simply code to
stay updated with all the latest tech
content also hit that Bell icon to never
miss an update from us so without any
further delay let's get started with
today's topic
firstly let us discuss the agenda for
today's session we'll start the tutorial
by understanding what SQL syntax is and
why we use it next we'll understand what
are SQL expressions and SQL statements
then we'll discuss about SQL data types
followed by SQL operators
next we'll go through SQL commands and
its types
after that we'll discuss the syntax of
ddl commands followed by DML commands
and finally we'll have a look at the
syntax of DCL commands as well
what is SQL syntax
just like other programming languages
SQL follows a unique set of rules and
guidelines called syntax we use Simple
English words in the SQL syntax in order
to execute various queries
syntax is by default case insensitive
that means the system allows the user to
write the queries in both uppercase as
well as lowercase but if you are working
with mySQL server then you need to give
table names exactly as they exist in the
database
we know that rdbms is the basis for all
modern database systems including SQL
which manages and performs various
operations on the tables like insert
update modify and delete
so in order to retrieve the data stored
in the database it is necessary to learn
SQL syntax first
before we move ahead with the topic if
you want to learn more about the basics
of dbms and SQL make sure you check out
our previous playlist videos on
introduction to dbms and SQL on our
Channel
we'll leave the link in the description
below
SQL Expressions SQL expression is a
combination of one or more keywords and
values operators data types and other
SQL functions these SQL expressions are
like a formula which are similar to
mathematical formulas which we generally
use to solve a problem and in this case
the written in a query language using a
proper syntax
SQL statement SQL statements are
basically collection of SQL expressions
for example let us consider an employee
table to understand it in a better way
the table is having attributes like
employee ID name age City and salary
now if I want to fetch the record of all
the employees and their IDs I'll write a
simple SQL query
that is Select ID comma name from
employee here select is the database
object or the keyword that is used ID
and name are the columns from employee
employee is the name of the table when I
execute this query this will be the
output it will display the ID and name
of the employee
let us look at another query now I want
to display uh the salary of employees
having uh more than 30 000. for that I
am using the query as select ID name
from employee where salary is greater
than 30 000. here where is the
conditional statement that I'm using or
it is a SQL clause also we are using
greater than symbol which is an SQL
operator
so with the help of Escape statements we
can fetch uh the records
of all the information from SQL tables
SQL data types SQL data type specifies
which type of values is stored in the
database tables SQL data types are
mainly classified into three categories
the first one is numeric numerical data
refers to the data that is in the form
of numbers a numerical data type we have
different uh types as well for example
INT in holds values of integers and
whole numbers without any decimal point
further they are again divided into
small end and begins also the difference
between them is the size and range of
the value they can store and operate
bit data type is an integer data type
that can only take values of 0 1 or any
null value SQL optimizes storage of bit
columns if a table has eight or fewer
bit columns SQL stores them as one byte
if a table has 9 or up to 16 bit columns
SQL stores them as two bytes and so on
float float stores the numbers having
decimal values depending upon the number
of digits after the decimal point SQL
gives the size accordingly in its range
Boolean it is used to specify Boolean
values that is true and false 0 is
considered as false and non-zero values
are considered as true
string data type string data types
allows us to store fixed or variable
character values they are again further
divided into various types the first one
is care car is used to specify a fixed
length string that can contain numbers
letters and special characters its size
can be 0 to 255 characters
similar to care but it stores variable
lens strings and size of wire care is
also more than the car data type with a
range of 0 to almost 60 000 characters
so if you're storing strings with a
widely variable lens such as name
address email ID then we have to use a
bearcare
text text data type stores any kind of
text Data it can hold string value that
can contain maximum length of 255
characters
date time in SQL daytime data type is
used for storing values that can contain
both date as well as time
the first one is date it is used to
specify date format that is year month
date in this data type we can store only
the value of data
and the next one is date time it is used
to specify the combination of both date
and time the format is year month date
Hearts minutes and seconds for instance
I have taken the example as 2022
3 that is the month 20 is the date 23
hours 59 is the minutes and 59 is the
seconds
timestamp it is also similar to daytime
data type the format specification is
also the same as well the only
difference is it has less a range of
values to store it is also used to
convert current time into various time
zones like UTC GMT Etc
we also have XML and Json data types
which are not that significant and we do
not use as frequently as other data
types in SQL
SQL operators SQL operators are used to
specify certain conditions in an SQL
statement SQL operators are broadly
classified into five categories the
first one is arithmetic arithmetic
operators perform mathematical operation
on numerical data on the SQL tables
these operation performs addition
subtraction multiplication and division
operations on the numerical operands the
next one is logical The Logical
operators in SQL perform Boolean
operations which gives two results
either true or false these operators
provide True Value if both operands
match The Logical condition some logical
operators are and not are between
Etc
comparison the comparison operator is in
SQL Compares two different data
in the SQL tables and checks whether
they are same greater or lesser the SQL
comparison operator are used with a
conditional Clause where in the SQL
queries
equal to is highly used uh comparison
operator in SQL
bitwise bitwise operators perform bit
manipulations between two expressions of
any integer data type category bitwise
operators convert two integer values to
Binary bits and perform and or are not
operation on each bit which finally
gives the required result
final one is set the set operators in
SQL combine a similar type of data from
two or more SQL database tables
basically it merges the result which is
extracted from two or more SQL queries
into a single result SQL Union intersect
and minus operators are some of the
examples of set operations
SQL commands we know that SQL commands
are broadly classified into four types
the first one is data definition
language ddl ddl allows the user to
define the table and make changes to its
overall structure commands that are used
in ddlr create it is used to create a
new table
alter it is used to modify the existing
table by adding new attributes drop it
is used to delete the whole table and
the data stored in it
truncate it is used to delete the rows
in a table
now that we have got the idea and
understanding of various operators data
types and commands let us look at the
syntax of all these commands
the first one is SQL create statement
perhaps one of the most important and
used SQL statement because if you want
to create a table you have to first name
the table and then specify the columns
and the columns data types
so let us look at the syntax of create
statements
the syntax is followed as a create table
which is the keyword that is used
followed by table name that you want to
create and within the parenthesis you
have to mention the column give space
and add the data type
so in this way you can add a number of
columns and mention the data types but
make sure guys you have to give the
appropriate data type for the columns
that you have taken because there might
be a chance there might be instance
where you have you have given the column
such as age and you are mentioning data
type as character care which is
basically a mismatch the computer
doesn't accept it because generally age
is basically a numerical value but you
are mentioning care but it should
ideally be int to store the data so just
keep an eye on it when you are creating
new tables so let us now look at an
example of create statement so I want to
create a table name employee for that I
am writing as create table space
employee and within the uh parenthesis I
am mentioning employee ID as my first
column space int which is a data type
and I'm giving name worker address
worker close the parenthesis and put a
semicolon and if you execute this
statement this will be the following
result it will display uh the table with
different columns with the First Column
as employee ID the second column is name
and the third column as address
easy right
the next one is SQL alter table
the SQL order statement is basically is
used to add a modify or even delete you
know certain columns from the existing
table let us look at the syntax of SQL
order command
so the SQL alter command is altered
table space table name that you have to
mention
add and within the parenthesis you have
to mention the column and the data type
similarly you can add a number of data
types as per requirement
let us now look at one of the example
now I wanted to add the date of birth of
the employee in a new column for that
I'll write as alter table employee at
and within the parenthesis date of birth
and I'll mention the data type as well
which is the date and if you execute
this it will show the result like this
it will add another column date of birth
in already existing table
now due to certain reasons if you want
to drop or delete the date of birth
column for that we have to write syntax
as alter table give the employee
table name drop column which is the
keyword we use and date of birth so this
will be the final output when you
execute the query it will completely
drop the date of birth from the table
next we'll look at SQL drop statement
a skill drop statement basically removes
all the data and it changes the overall
structure of the table by deleting the
records in the table so let us look at
the syntax the syntax followed is a drop
table followed by the table name that we
want to create
let us look one of the example uh the
syntax followed is a drop table employee
and when I execute this it will show an
error stating that table employed does
not exist which means you have
completely deleted all the records uh
from the employee table
SQL truncate statement
let us look at the SQL truncate
statement syntax the syntax is truncate
table which is the keyword that is used
and we have to specify the table name
for example if you want to truncate the
values in employee table we have to
write truncate table employee so this
will be the output where it shows null
that is uh there are no values in the
employee table and you can further add
values of your own choice
let us now look at data manipulation
language
data manipulation language or DML
is used to access and manipulate data
tables commands that are used in DML are
insert it is used to insert new values
into the table
select it is used to extract data from
the tables
update it is used to update values in
the already existing table
delete unlike the drop command delete
command is used to delete a specific row
or all the rows on the table
let us first look at the SQL in search
statement
the syntax followed in SQL insert
statement is insert into which is the
keyword that we use space table name
that we have created values and inside
the parenthesis you have to mention the
values
there is also another method to insert
the values where we specify the column
name as well as the values
now if you execute this
so but before executing we'll take an
example uh we are creating a table
student and we are inserting values such
as roll number name age and City so the
roll number uh is given as one uh the
name is given as Rohan the age is given
as 22 and the city is given as Hyderabad
for the first row similarly uh we'll do
the same for the next two rows as well
and if you execute this query this will
be the final output where you'll have
four different uh columns having uh the
First Column as rule number the next one
having name age city with the roll
numbers as one or Rohan 22 Hyderabad and
the second row consists of the Roll
number two anjana uh age being 20 and
the City Bangalore and the third one is
roll number three the name is kaushal
age 21 and the city is Mumbai
SQL select statement let us now look at
the uh syntax of SQL select statement
the SQL is followed the syntax is
followed as select column one column two
and a number of columns from the table
name
and if you want to uh display all the
names from the table you have to use
asterisk that is Select star from table
name let us look at the example
so I want to display the roll number
name age from the student table for that
I'll write select roll number
comma name comma H from the table that
is student and if I execute this it will
only display roll number name age of the
students and it will not display the
city of the students
and if you want to display uh even the
city uh
to which they belong we have to write
select star from student then it will
display even the city in the uh table
SQL select condition statement
consider employee table uh with having
ID name age City and salary
and if you want to specifically uh you
know display uh the employees name uh
who live in a city New Delhi you have to
write select star from employee where
city is equals to New Delhi here we are
applying a condition that is where which
is a SQL clause and we are using an
operator as well which is equal to and
if you execute this statement it will
show this as output where you will find
the ID of alexing Ravi Patel who belong
to the city New Delhi
SQL update statement
it is used to update already existing
values in the statement for example if
you consider the syntax it is followed
as update space table name that you have
created set column name equals to new
value that is the updated value that you
want to keep into the new table and you
have to keep a condition as well that is
where condition
let us look an example now if you want
to update the student table and if I
want to insert uh if I want to change
the city of the Roll number three that
is kaushals uh City uh I'll write as
update student set CT equals to Chennai
where roll number is equals to 3 and
when you execute this it will show like
this
so the city uh which is Mumbai has been
changed into Chennai
SQL delete statement
SQL delete statement is is used to
delete a specific row or even all the
rows from the table the syntax is delete
from table name
for example if you want to delete all
the records from the student table we
will write it as delete from student
semicolon so this will be the output it
will only display the column names and
the data inside it will be completely
erased
and if you want to delete only a certain
number of rows we have to use Query as
delete from student where roll number is
equals to 1 and when you execute this
query it will show like this it will
completely erase the records of the Roll
number one student
and the final one is data control
language or DCL
DCL is responsible for maintaining the
security which use control access and
permissions of the database commands
that come under dclr Grant it is used to
Grant the permission to user to access
the database revoke it is used to cancel
or take back the permissions that were
earlier granted
let us now look at SQL Grant statement
sometimes user is restricted from
creating or making any changes within
the table but with the help of Grant
statement we can give privilege to the
user to create or modify the records in
the table
let us now look at the syntax of SQL
Grant statement it is followed as Grant
space privilege list that is basically
the set of commands that you are giving
access of permission to the user to
perform certain operations on the table
that you have created to user we have to
mention the username example Grant
insert select on employee to Rahul that
means Rahul is able to access the
employee table and can perform a command
such as insert and select
SQL revoke statement SQL revoke
statement is basically the opposite of
Grant statement it is used to take back
the permissions that were earlier
granted the similar the syntax is also
similar to the grant statement instead
of Grant keyword you have to replace it
by revoke let us look at the example
revoke insert on employee from Rahul
that means Rahul is no longer able to
insert new values into the employee
table
let us dive straight into today's topic
on SQL operators
firstly let us discuss the agenda for
today's session we'll start the tutorial
by understanding what SQL operators are
then we'll go through different types of
SQL operators and finally we look at the
syntax of various operators and execute
them in MySQL workbench
what are SQL operators SQL operators are
basically reserved words or special
characters that are used to query a
database
provides us with many such operators to
ease the process of data manipulation
SQL operators are used to perform
various tasks including complex
mathematical operations like arithmetic
and binary
to query a database using operators we
use a where Clause operators are
necessary to define a condition in SQL
as they act as a connector between two
or more SQL statements based on the
operator functionality it manipulates
the data accordingly and gives the
result
types of SQL operators SQL operators are
mainly classified into three types the
first one is arithmetic operators the
arithmetic operators perform the
mathematical operation or numerical data
of SQL tables that further classified as
addition operator the addition operator
is used to perform addition or numerical
data using this we can add values of
single or multiple columns in the table
subtraction operator subtraction
operator in SQL performs the subtraction
on the numerical data of the database
table
multiplication operator multiplication
operator in SQL performs multiplication
on the data items in SQL we can easily
multiply the numerical values of two or
more Columns of the same table by
specifying both the column names as the
first and second operand and finally
division operator division operator in
SQL divides the operand on the left side
by the operand on the right side we can
also divide the numerical values of one
column by another column of the same
table by specifying both column names as
the first and second operand
let us now look at the execution part of
the arithmetic operations on MySQL
workbench
as you can see workbench has started but
before we proceed to the syntax of SQL
operators we have to first create a
database and then we have to create a
table within the database so for time
being I've already created a table named
employee so let us just briefly go
through the syntax of create table
so the syntax is followed as create
table space now we can declare the
employee that is the table name in two
ways that is you can directly mention
the table name that is employee or else
you can mention database dot table name
that is employee and after that in the
parenthesis you have to mention the
column names followed by its appropriate
data types so as far as this table
employees concerned I have taken a
column names as ID name age City and
salary
and also have chosen primary key as ID
as it uniquely identifies each and every
record in the table
close the parenthesis and put a
semicolon
now that you have created a table you
have to insert values into the table and
for that we use insert command so the
Syntax for insert command is insert into
space table name that is employee and
within the parenthesis you have to
mention all the column names that you
have taken in the single quotes
after that close the parenthesis and you
have to write values which is the
keyword and mention different values as
per your choice accordingly that you
have taken into the columns so in this
way you can insert n number of Records
into the table using insert command for
this employee table I have taken out
values total of 10 values
now that you have created and inserted
values into your table and if you want
to display all the records of the
employees you have to uh write you have
to select the query as
select
star
from
the table name that is employee
and when you execute this
it will show the records of all the
employees that you have taken that is
their ID their name age City and salary
so we have taken total 10 values and it
will be displayed
now that we have understood all these
let us proceed with the SQL operators
first let us look at a addition operator
uh let us understand this with an help
of an example suppose you want to add 10
000 to the salary of each employee
specified in the table then we have to
write the query as
select
salary
plus 10 000.
as I'm taking a new column that is
employee new salary
to specify all these values into the
column
as employee new salary
from the table name that is employee
now when you execute this
it will show the result like this that
is it will add 10 000 to each and
everyone's values that is 30 000 has
been changed into forty thousand twenty
eight thousand has been changed into 38
000 and so on
now if I want to display their ID name
their previous salary and the final
salary simultaneously I'll write the
query as select ID
comma space name space
salary
space salary plus 10 000 as employees
new salary from employee
now if I execute this
it will display like this that is it
will uh mention the ID name the previous
salary and employee new salary
simultaneously
so in this way you can add two or more
columns in the same table using addition
operator
let us now look at subtraction operator
subtraction operator is also similar to
that of addition operator the only
difference is you have to replace the
plus sign
with the minus sign so again for this
example uh let us say uh if you want to
subtract 2000 from salary of each
employee given in the employee table
then we have to write the query as
select
ID
comma space and name
comma space salary
minus 2000
as
employee new salary
from the table that is employee
so let us execute this
and it will show the new values that is
2000 has been deducted from the salary
of each and every employee as you can
see 30 000 has been reduced to twenty
eight thousand twenty eight thousand has
been reduced to twenty six thousand
thirty five thousand has been reduced to
thirty three thousand and so on
so next let us look at the
multiplication operator
again let us take the same example uh if
you want to multiply the salary of each
and every employee
uh then you have to write the query as
select
ID
name
salary
into two we are using asterisk operator
as the multiplication sign here
as
employ
new salary
from the table name that is employee
now if you execute this
I will show the values like uh in this
way that is the salary has been doubled
if you as you can see the employer Rahul
salary 30 000 has been multiplied uh and
has changed into 60 000 that is doubled
28 000 has been doubled to fifty six
thousand and so on
so in this way you can apply
multiplication operator and finally let
us look at a division operator
let us take the same example uh suppose
let's say if you want to divide the
salary of each and every employee then
you have to write the query as select
ID
name
salary
divided by two
as employing your salary
from the table name that is employee
and put a semicolon let us now execute
this
and as you can see the salary has been
divided uh into half uh Rahul salary 30
000 has been changed to fifteen thousand
Kiran salary 28 000 has been changed to
40 14 000 and so on so in this way you
can use automatic operations to perform
various uh operations on your table that
is addition subtraction multiplication
and division
the second type of SQL operators are
comparison operators the comparison
operators in SQL Compares two different
data of SQL tables and check whether
they are same greater and lesser the SQL
comparison operators are used with a
conditional Clause where in the SQL
queries they are again further divided
into various types the first one is
equal to SQL equal to operator is one of
the popular and most frequently used
operators in SQL queries it shows only
that data which matches the specified
value in the query
less than the less than operator in SQL
shows only those data from the database
tables which are less than the value of
the right right hand side operand
greater than the greater than operator
in SQL shows only those data which are
greater than the value of right hand
operand
we also have less than equals to and
greater than equals to operators as well
which basically shows the data in the
tables which are less than and equals to
as well as greater than equals to the
value of the right hand operands
let us look at the syntax and execute
them in the workbench
firstly let us look at the equal to
operator
let's say if you want to access the
records of all those employees who are
having salary uh equals to 40 000 so for
that we'll write the query as select
star
from the table
that is employee
we have to use the conditional statement
where
salary
is equals to forty thousand
and put a semicolon when you execute
this
it will show the records of all those
employees who are having salary equals
to 40 000 as you can see it is showing
three IDs uh uh pranay Anusha and Prem
who are having service is forty thousand
next let us look at uh not equals to not
equals to is basically the opposite of
equal to and uh
to understand this let us take an
example suppose if we want to access the
records of all those employees whose
salary is not equals to uh 35 000. so
for that we'll write the query as select
star
from the table that is employee
where
let us put the keyword in the upper case
where salary
not equals to 35 000.
let us execute this and let us see the
output
so as you can see it will display the
records of all those employees who are
not having the salary uh 35 000 so it
will display the record such as rahul's
Kiran pranay Anusha varsha who are
having salices thirty thousand twenty
eight thousand forty thousand twenty
three thousand and so on which are
basically not equals to thirty five
thousand
next let us look at a greater than
operator
uh for this let us take an example for
instance if you want to access the
records of all those employees from the
employee table uh whose ID is greater
than one or four so for that we'll write
the following query as
select
star
from the table that is employee
where
ID greater than 104.
for a semicolon and let us execute this
so as you can see it will display the
records of all those employees uh who
are having ID greater than one or four
that is it will display from one not
five and up until 110.
similarly uh we have the less than
operator as well
which is basically the opposite of
greater than operator for that
uh
we'll take an example uh such as if you
want to display the records of all those
employees who are having ID less than
1.5 so for that we'll write the query as
select
star
from the table that is employee
where
ID
is less than one not five
let us execute this
so as you can see it will display all
those records of the employees who are
having less than 1.5 that is it will
display the records of the employees one
not one one or two one not three and one
naught for IDs
next let us look at greater than equals
to
greater than equals to is also similar
to that of greater than but the thing is
we are also mentioning the equal to
operator as well
so for instance let's say if you want to
access the records of all those
employees in the employee table who are
having salary greater than or equals to
40 000. so for that we'll write the
query as select star
from the table employee
where
salary
greater than equals to forty thousand
let's execute this
and this is this will be the output it
will show the records of all those
employees who are having salary greater
than or equals to forty thousand so in
this case it will display a total of
four records of the employee table
similarly let us look at the less than
equals to operator as well
which basically uses less than and equal
to operator
so suppose if you want to access the
records of all those employees from the
employee table who's having salary or
let's say less than or equals to thirty
thousand so for that uh we'll have to
write the following query as select
star
from employee
where
salary
less than or equals to thirty thousand
so let us execute this
and the output will be like this that is
it will display all the employer Records
who are having salary less than or
equals to thirty thousand a total of
three records that is ID employee ID is
one not one one or two one or six are
being displayed because we are having
salary is thirty thousand twenty eight
thousand twenty three thousand which are
basically less than or equals to thirty
thousand
so in this way you can use comparison
operator to perform various operations
on your data
and finally we have logical operators
The Logical operators in SQL perform
Boolean operations which Give two
results either true or false these
operators provide True Value if both
operands match The Logical condition and
vice versa
various logical operators in SQL are and
are not and between let us understand
the syntaxes and execute them in the
workbench now
firstly let us discuss about the and
operator and operator in SQL will show
the records from a database table if all
the conditions separated by the and
operator is evaluated to be true let us
understand with an example let's say if
you want to access the records of all
those employees from the employee table
whose salary is greater than 25 000 and
the city that they belong to is
Hyderabad so for that we'll write the
following query as select star
from table name that is employee
where
salary
is greater than 25 000
and
the city that they belong to is
Hyderabad
so when you execute this statement
the following output will will be
this that is it will display the total
three records of the employees that is
Rahul Kiran and Chinmay who are having
salaries more than 25 000 and the city
that they belong to is Hyderabad so in
this way and operator in SQL is used to
compare data with more than one
condition if and only if all the
conditions return true then only it will
display the records otherwise it won't
next let us look at the r operator
our operator in SQL shows the records
from the table if any of the conditions
separated by the or operator evaluates
to be true
let us understand with an example for
instance if you want to display the
records of employees from the employee
table who are whose salary is greater
than 30 000 or the city that they belong
to is Bangalore so the following query
would be select star
from the table that is employee
where
salary is less than 30 000
or the city that they belong to is
Bangalore
let us execute this statement now
so this will be the following output
where you can see a total of four
records of the employees uh followed by
Kirin pranay varsha and Rohit who are
having Salvage less than thirty thousand
orange that Belong To The City Bangalore
so in this way we can use our operator
which basically compares the data with
more than one condition and unlike and
operator if either of the condition is
true it will return the data otherwise
it won't
next let us look at the between operator
between operator in SQL shows the record
within a specified range mentioned in
the SQL query if there is no value in
this given range then this operator
shows null value
suppose if you want to access the
information of all the employees from
the employee table whose salary is in
between 25
000 and 35 000 then we'll write the
following query as select star
from table name that is employee
where
salary
between
and 30 35 000.
let us execute this query now
so following is the output where it will
display the records of all those
employees who are having sales in
between 25 000 and 35 000.
and finally let us look at the not
operator
not operator in SQL shows the records
from the table if the condition
evaluates to be false that means the not
operator is also called as a negation or
a negate operator which shows data for
the opposite of the conditions that we
mentioned in the SQL statement
let us understand this with the help of
an example let's say if you want to
access the information of all those
employees from the table who are not
having salary as 40 000 so for that
we'll write the syntax as
select
star
from table name that is employee
where
not
salary
equals to forty thousand
so let us execute this query now
so as you can see it will display all
the records of those employees who are
not having the salary as 40 000. so if
you want to upskill yourself in the
field of data analytics and become
proficient in SQL and database
management then our postgraduate program
in data analytics in partnership with
Purdue University and in collaboration
with IBM can help you with that this
course features master classes and
follows an applied learning model
designed with real life projects and
business case studies which will help
you boost your career so what are you
waiting for enroll now and take
advantage of this amazing opportunity
you can find the course Link in the
description box below I'll start this
tutorial by understanding what SQL
expressions are then we'll go through
different types of SQL expressions and
finally we'll look at the syntax of
various SQL expressions and execute them
in MySQL workbench with examples
so what are the SQL Expressions SQL
expressions are composed of one or more
keywords or values such as operators
operands and various other functions
that evaluate to a single value or a set
of values for a given SQL statement
these SQL expressions are like a formula
which are similar to that of
mathematical formulas we use to solve a
problem and in this case they are
written in a query language using a
proper syntax to perform operations on
the data we have stored in our database
table for example consider the basic
syntax of the select statement here
expressions are used in many contexts
such as to retrieve any value from the
table we use select command and for
comparison we use where Clause so in
this case all these are SQL Expressions
only
types of SQL Expressions SQL Expressions
can be classified into following
categories the first one is Boolean
expression SQL Boolean Expressions fetch
data based on one-to-one matching in
other words we can think of it as a
query that fetches one result at a time
it will fetch the condition against the
single value when the query is executed
the second one is numeric expression SQL
numeric expression is used for
performing mathematical operations in
SQL query besides automatic operations
there are several built-in functions
like average sum count as well
date expression SQL date expressions are
used to compare and get date according
to its various date and time related
query and conditions they give date time
value as the output it can also return
current system date and time values also
now that we have understood what exactly
SQL expressions are let's execute them
in MySQL workbench with the help of
examples
as you can see SQL workbench has started
and before we get to the execution part
of various SQL Expressions we have to
first create a table so for that I've
already created a table named student
within the database simply code the
student table consists of various
columns such as roll number name of the
student age the city they belong to date
of birth the stream that they have
chosen and the total marks that they
have scored in the final exam and here
the primary key is roll number which
basically uniquely identifies each and
every record of the students in the
table
so now that we have created the table if
we want to retrieve the information of
all the students we'll use select
command so the following query would be
select
star
from the table name that is student
and semicolon
let us execute this
and as you can see all the records of
the students are being displayed that is
the name their age the city they belong
to the stream and also the total marks
that they have scored in the final exam
now that we have created table and
inserted values into the table let us
understand various SQL Expressions
firstly let us discuss about Boolean
expression
for that we'll take a simple example
from the table itself
suppose let's say you want to display
the records of those students from the
student table who belong to the city
Kochi for that we'll write the SQL query
as
select
star
from the table name that is student
where
City
equals to Kochi
now let us execute this statement and
see the output
so as you can see there's a student
named Divya whose ages 21 Who belongs to
the city Kochi similarly you can find
for other cities as well so let us take
for Pune and execute this query
so the output would be uh it will show
the records of two students named Aman
and Indra who's having age 22 and 25 who
belong to the city Pune and having our
streams is triple an MBA and the total
Marxist 922 and 972.
so the Boolean expression not only
executes the values against the
character values which is in this case
is Pune but it can also take the values
of numerical values as well for example
let's say uh the university has got to
know the highest marks scored by an
individual in the final exam is 988 and
it wants to retrieve the details of that
student so for that the following query
would be
select
star
from table name that is student
where
total marks
is equals to 988
let us execute this query now
so as you can see a student named pratik
Who belongs to the stream CAC has scored
the highest marks 988 so in this way
Boolean expressions are used to perform
various operations which basically
evaluates a given condition to a
particular value or you can say a single
value and if the condition is true it
will return the output and display all
those records otherwise it won't
up next we have numeric expression
numeric expressions
so numeric expressions are basically
used to perform various mathematical
operations so let us understand this
with an example for instance let's say
the university has decided to change the
total marks weightage from 1000 to 500
and I'll specify a condition where I'll
take the total marks and divide them
into half and check all the students who
have scored more than 480 out of 500 for
that the following query would be select
star
from the table that is student
where
total marks
divided by 2
is greater than 480.
put a semicolon and let us execute this
so as you can see there are total four
students who have scored more than 480
when that when the total marks are
divided into half for instance if you
take uh the record of Rohan who has
scored total marks 977 and if you
divided it by 2 that is approximately
488.5 which is satisfying the condition
which that is greater than 480.
and if you look at this SQL statement
carefully there are a lot of SQL
Expressions here firstly the student
table name that is the student itself
because it is used to retrieve the
values from the columns that is uh here
the total marks is the column and we
also have the operands that is total
months divided by 2 and the right hand
operand that is 480 which can also be
considered as an SQL expression here
similarly we have other inbuilt
functions as we discussed earlier like
some average count minimum and maximum
let's say if you want to calculate the
average of total marks of each and every
student scored in the final exam the
following query would be
select
average which is the SQL function
and within the parenthesis
mentioned total marks
total marks
from the table that is M student
let us execute this
as you can see it is displaying the
total average of total marks that is 954
4.375
similarly you can calculate the sum of
all the marks of the students as well so
the query would be select sum
total marks
total marks from the student table
foreign let us execute this
and this will be the following output
so there is a bit error in the code let
me check it once
so as you can see it is displaying the
sum of total marks that is
7635. so in this way you can use numeric
Expressions to perform various
operations on the SQL tables
and finally we have date expression
which basically returns date and time
values of the table say let's say if you
want to uh display the records of those
students who are born after 1995 January
so for that the following query would be
select star
from the table name that is student
where
date of birth is greater than
January 1st
so let us execute this query and see the
output
as you can see there are total uh five
records of the students who are born
after January 1995.
similarly you can also display the
current date and time as well using the
current timestamp function that is
Select
current timestamp
current times done
and let us execute this query
so as you can see it will display the
current
year uh the date and the month format
similarly it is also displaying the ER
time which is in the format of hours
minutes and seconds
so in this way you can use various
Expressions to query the database for a
specific set of data to retrieve the
information from the SQL tables firstly
let us discuss the agenda for today's
session we'll start the tutorial by
understanding what SQL databases are and
look at some popular SQL databases after
that we'll discuss how to create an SQL
database in MySQL workbench next we'll
see how to select the database in MySQL
and finally we'll discuss how to delete
the already created database as well
what is SQL database a database in
general is a collection of organized
data for easier access so that it can be
managed and stored effectively as far as
SQL databases are concerned a relational
database is used to store and manage all
the data in the form of tables simple
SQL queries are returned to retrieve the
data from these SQL database tables in a
nutshell you can see that SQL is used to
connect with the databases as it
directly interacts and communicates with
the database to retrieve the information
stored in tables
popular SQL databases some popular SQL
databases are MySQL Microsoft SQL Server
Oracle database postglue SQL and mongodb
these are some databases that are being
widely used nowadays by many companies
each of them function in their own way
and also the syntax of queries that are
written can also slightly vary from each
other as well
let us now discuss the first topic of
today's session that is SQL create
database in SQL creating a new database
is the first and foremost step to store
the data in the tables so in order to
create a database users must use create
database as a keyword in the syntax so
the syntax is followed as create
database that is the keyword that we are
using here followed by the name of the
database name
in the syntax database name specifies
the name of the database which you want
to create in the system also make sure
that the database you're creating has a
unique name and it does not match with
other databases as well for example if
you look at the following example I am
creating a database named student so the
syntax would be create database followed
by the database name that is student so
let us now run the syntax on MySQL
workbench and see how it is executed in
real time
as you can see MySQL has opened and if
you look carefully at the interface of
MySQL workbench on the left hand side
you will find schemas or the various
databases that are available in the
system at the center you'll find the SQL
editor where the queries are written and
at the bottom you will find the console
where you can see the status or the
output of the query that has been
executed so firstly let's go ahead and
discuss the first topic that is how to
create a database let's say if you want
to create a new database a project so
the create database statement would be
as followed
create database
that is the keyword that is used to
create a new database followed by that
we have to specify the database name
that is Project
put a semicolon and let us execute this
as you can see our database project has
been successfully executed and if you
refresh the schema you will find the
database name as project so in this way
you can create a new project and just
for confirmation if you want to check
the databases created or not you can
check it in the list of databases by
using show databases
keyword so let us see and execute this
so as you can see these are the various
databases that are available in the
system including our database project
that we have created earlier
let us now discuss our next topic that
is how to select a database
now that you have created a database now
the user wants to perform some
operations like creating a new table and
inserting values onto the existing
database in SQL for that firstly they
have to select the database on which
they want to run the database queries
without selecting the database they
cannot create a new table for instance
if I want to create a new table
that is student and when I execute this
query
it will throw our error stating that no
database selected select the default
database to be used so in this way you
won't be able to create a new table
without selecting the database
any database user can easily select the
particular database from the current
database server using the use keyword in
the SQL statement so the following
syntax would be use
followed by the database name
that you want to select for example let
us take for instance if I want to work
on the database project so the following
query would be
use
project which is the
database name here let us execute this
so as you can see the query has been
successfully executed and
also you can find the database name
project is highlighted in a bold that
means you have successfully selected the
database and you can start creating your
new tables
so in this way when you have multiple
databases in your SQL schema before
starting your operations you have to
select a database where all the
operations would be performed also keep
in mind that the database that you are
selecting should be unique
finally let us look at how to drop the
database
in other words dropping a database is to
delete a database the SQL drop database
statement deletes the existing database
permanently from the database system
that means the statement deletes all the
data and the tables that are stored in
the database so let us now look at the
syntax of the drop database the syntax
is followed as drop database
followed by the database name that is
Project
here in a SQL syntax we have specified
the name of the database which we wanted
in it permanently from the database
system after the drop database keyword
and let us execute this and see the
output
as you can see the database has been
dropped and even at the left hand side
if you look at the schemas database
project has been deleted successfully
so in this way you can delete a database
using drop database statement but be
careful before using this operation
because by deleting an existing database
it would result in complete loss of
information stored in the database we'll
understand how data is stored in the
form of tables in SQL and also discuss
some basic SQL queries related to these
tables but before we get started if
you're new to the channel and haven't
subscribed yet make sure to subscribe to
our Channel simply code to stay updated
with all the latest tech content and hit
that Bell icon to never miss an update
from us so without any further Ado let's
get started with today's topic
firstly let us discuss the agenda for
today's session we'll start the tutorial
by understanding what is SQL table and
then we'll look at how to create a table
after that we'll see how to drop a table
followed by that we'll see how to insert
a new value into the table and then we
look how to delete a table after that
we'll see how to truncate a particular
table and then we'll discuss how to
alter an existing Table after that we'll
see how to rename an existing table
finally we look at how to copy a new
table
what is SQL table tables are the
essential elements of a database and in
particular for relational databases as
it is one of the most used data models
to store and retrieve data from tables
tables are basically an organized
collection of data that consists of rows
and columns another point to be noted is
that a table has a specified number of
columns but can have any number of rows
let us understand this with an example
here the name of the table is taken as
an employee and in SQL naming a table is
very important because before performing
any operation you have to specify the
name also the name of the table should
be unique and it should not match with
other tables in the database the
horizontal values represented in the
tables are called as rows or tuples and
each row represents a unique record
similarly the vertical values represent
columns or the attributes of that
particular table and each column
represents a unique field in the record
as we can see in the table employee ID
employee name job department number
salary are the various fields or the
column names the data in this multiple
columns such as the employee name Rohan
who's having employee 2011 who is
working as a data analyst belong to the
department three and having salary 50
000 is stored in the form of rows
I hope you've understood what is an SQL
table now so let us now discuss some
basic SQL queries that are performed on
these tables and execute them in MySQL
workbench as well
SQL create table
SQL create table is foremost thing to do
in SQL if you want to create a table you
should name the table and Define its
columns and each columns data type let
us now look at the syntax of create
table the syntax is followed as create
table which is the keyword used here
followed by that we have to mention the
table name and within the parenthesis
you have to mention the column names
followed by that you have to mention the
data type in this way you can add a
number of columns as per your choice now
that we have understood the syntax let
us jump into MySQL workbench and execute
this
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
as you can see MySQL workbench has
started and on the left side you can see
that simply code is the database which
we are working on and in that database
we are going to create a new table so
let us now look at the syntax of create
a table so the syntax is followed as
create table which is the keyword we are
using followed by that we have to
specify the table name that is we have
taken employee in this case and within
the brackets or the parenthesis you have
to mention the column names followed by
that you have to mention the data types
here I have taken column names as ID
name City job and salary
and finally I have chosen the primary
key as ID because it uniquely identifies
each and every record in the table
in the end you have to close the
brackets and mention semicolon let us
now execute this query and see the
output
as you can see our table is successfully
created so in order to display the
values or whether or not our table is
created or not we have we have the query
as select
star
from the table name that is employee
let us execute this and see the output
as you can see the table is created and
it is showing the column names as ID
name CT job and salary so in this way
you can create a new table
next let us discuss about dropped table
drop table in other words is basically
is to delete a table the SQL drop table
statement is used to remove the table
definition and the overall structure of
the existing table be careful that while
using this command because once a table
is deleted then all the information
available in the data will also be lost
forever the Syntax for the drop table is
drop table and then you have to mention
the table name
so let us now look at the example now
for some reasons if I want to delete the
employee table so the syntax would be
dropped table
followed by that the name of the table
that is employee let us execute this
as you can see our table is completely
dropped and let us now see if it is
actually deleted or not for that we'll
use select
statement
select star
from the table name that is employee
let me execute this query
as you can see it is throwing an error
stating that table simply code.employ
does not exist this means you've
successfully deleted the existing table
employee
let us now discuss the next topic that
is SQL insert table SQL insert statement
is used to add new rows of data into a
table this can be a single or multiple
records into the database the Syntax for
the insert table is insert into which is
the keyword followed by that table name
and within the parenthesis you have to
mention the column names values and
again within the parenthesis you have to
mention the values so here the column 1
column two column 3 and in number of
columns are the names of the columns in
which the table you want to insert the
data into you may not need to specify
the column names in the SQL query if you
are adding values for all the columns of
the table but make sure the order of the
values is in the same order as the
column in the table
let us jump into the execution part now
I'm taking the same name that is
employee table to insert the new values
so the Syntax for inserting new values
into the table is followed as insert
into table name that is employee and
within the brackets we have to mention
the columns that we have taken earlier
that is ID name City job and salary
after that we have to mention the values
using the values keyword So within the
brackets I'm mentioning the ID name
as101 name as Rohan the city that he
belongs to is Hyderabad and the job that
he does is Da that is data analyst and
the salary that he earns is 40 000 so
let me execute this query and see the
output
so as you can see our query has been
successfully implemented now let us
display the results by using select
query again let me select this whole
query and execute this
as you can see the details of employee
name that is Rohan whose ID is 101 and
is the CD he belongs to Hyderabad his
job data analyst his salary 40 000 is
being successfully displayed so in this
way you can insert new values into the
table
up next let us discuss about delay table
in SQL delete table in SQL is used to
remove rows from a table this can be a
complete Row from an existing table or a
specific row if you want to remove a
specific Row from a table you should use
where condition but if you do not
specify the where condition here it will
remove all the rows from the table the
Syntax for delete statement is delete
from the table name
so let us take an example now suppose if
I want to delete the records of the
employee who is having employee ID as
102 in the table employee so the
following query would be
delete
from table name that is employee
specify the where condition
keyword that is where
ID is equals to 1.2
let us execute this statement now
as you can see our statement has been
successfully executed now I'll display
the records by using select statement
as you can see the employee ID who's
having uh one or two has his employee ID
has been successfully deleted from the
table so in this way you can use direct
statement to delete a particular record
from the table
all right
let us now discuss about truncate table
in SQL truncie table statement is used
to remove all the rows from the table
that means it deletes the complete data
from an existing table it is similar to
that of delete statement but here we do
not use the where Clause tranquet table
is faster and uses lesser resources than
the delete table command as it deletes
the records at a single time drop table
command can also be used to delete the
complete data but it also deletes the
structure of the table as well truncate
table does not delete the structure of
the data so the Syntax for truncate
table is truncate table
and after that you have to mention the
table name
so if I want to delete all the records
from the employee table the following
query would be
truncate
table
followed by that you have to mention the
table name that is employee
let us execute this and see the output
so the query has been successfully
executed so let me use the select
statement to display the records
as you can see uh all the information of
the employee has been successfully
deleted from the table but if you look
at uh the output closely the structure
hasn't been deleted here the column
names of the table that is ID name City
job and salary have been retained but
only the values in the table have been
deleted so in this way you can use
truncate statement to delete all the
records from the table at a single time
make sure that uh you use this statement
carefully because the rollback process
is not possible after using truncate's
table statement that means if the data
is once deleted it is completely deleted
uh permanently
next let us discuss about SQL alter
table the order table in SQL
is used to add modify and delete Columns
of an existing table
in many situations you may require to
add columns in the existing table so
instead of creating a whole table again
and again you can easily add single or
multiple columns using alter table
statement with the help of a keyword add
let us now look at the syntax of alter
table the syntax is followed as alter
table table name add and within the
parenthesis you have to mention the new
column and the data type so let us now
jump into the execution part
consider the same table employee again
suppose if you want to add a new column
that is date of birth of the employee in
the above table for this you have to
type the following query as
alter table
mention the table name that is employee
after that mention the keyword add
and within the brackets mention the new
column name that is date of birth and
the data type of the date of birth is
date so I'll be mentioning the date data
type
close the brackets and put the semicolon
let us execute this statement now
as you can see our statement has been
successfully implemented and I'll use
the select statement to display the new
records
as you can see there's a new column
named date of birth has been
successfully added to our existing table
employee in this way you can use alter
table to add or delete the columns from
the table
let us now discuss about SQL rename
table
SQL rename table is used in SQL to
change the name of the table so in some
situations the database user might want
to change the name of the table so that
they want to give a more relevant name
or the updated name to the table any
database user can easily change the name
of the table by using rename table and
alter table statement in SQL
let us look at the syntax now the syntax
is followed as alter table
current Table name rename to new table
name
let us now execute this in MySQL
workbench
consider the same table employee again
and suppose if you want to change the
name of the above table employee into
let's say employee new for this you have
to type the following query that is
Alter
table
old table name that is employee
rename to is the keyword that you have
to use here
and mention the new table name we are
taking employee
new Azar new table name so let us
execute this and see the output
as you can see our statement has been
successfully executed so let let us
update the schema here and see whether
or not the name of the table is changed
so as you can see our table employee
which we had previously has been changed
into employee new in this way you can
use rename statement to give a new name
to your existing table
finally let us now look at SQL copy
table statement if you want to copy
the data of one SQL table into another
SQL table in the same SQL database then
it is possible by using the select into
statement in SQL the select into
statement in SQL copies the contents
from an existing table into a new table
SQL creates the new table by using the
structure of the existing table the
syntax is followed as select star into
new table name from the old table name
let us now execute this in MySQL
workbench and see the output
consider the same employee table again
and suppose you want to copy the content
of the employee table into a new table
let's say employee details now as far as
MySQL workbench is concerned there is a
slight change in the query now the
syntax that we've discussed earlier is
applicable to some other SQL databases
like Microsoft SQL server and Oracle
database but for MySQL workbench there
is a different syntax to copy a new
table so the syntax is followed as
create
table
mention the new table name that is
employee details
now select
star
from the old table name that is employee
let us now execute this and see the
output
now it will throw an error stating that
the employee table doesn't exist that's
because we have renamed our previous
employee name table into employee new so
instead of employee change it to employ
new and let us execute this statement
now
so
to in order to display if the employee
table is created successfully or not in
the database let us use select statement
to display the records select star from
the table name which is the new table
name that is employee
details
let us execute this now
as you can see uh the details that we
had earlier in our employee new table
has been copied into another table that
is employee details in this way you can
copy the content from one table existing
table from another new table by using
copy statement in SQL
and with that we have come to end of
today's session these were some of the
queries that were related to SQL tables
if you want to learn more about SQL make
sure to check out our previous playlist
in our Channel also we have a dedicated
video SQL full course 2022 for beginners
wherein we have discussed SQL and
various Concepts from the scratch
firstly let us discuss the agenda for
today's session we'll start the tutorial
by understanding what is SQL select
statement and then we'll discuss the
syntax of SQL select statement and
finally we'll go through some different
functions in SQL select statement
what is SQL select statement SQL select
statement is used to fetch the data from
a database table which Returns the data
in a form of a resultant table in simple
words we can say that it is used to
access the information from one or more
database tables within the database
let's look at the syntax of SQL select
statement the syntax is followed as
select column from table name in the
select syntax you can see column name 1
column name 2 and N number of columns
are the name of those columns in the
table whose data you wanted to read and
if you want to access all the rows from
all the fields of the table you can use
the select star operator in the database
by using select star from table name
command
let us look an example if you want to
retrieve the information of the student
who's having roll number name and age we
can write a simple query as select roll
number name age from student in this way
we can display the details of the
student
SQL select condition
select statement is used with various
Clauses as well that means it also
retrieves the selected data that follows
a particular condition with the help of
a where Clause by using this command we
can access a particular record from a
particular column of the table let's
understand this with an example consider
the employee table here which is having
ID name age City and salary as its
column in the table
let's say if you want to access the
information of those employees who's
having age as 29. for that we'll write a
simple query as select star from
employee where age is equals to 29 and
if you execute this this will be the
following output which shows the
information of those employees whose age
is 29 so in this way you can use SQL
select condition by specifying a where
statement which is used to filter the
data in a particular table
now that we have understood the basics
of SQL select statement let us now jump
into MySQL workbench and execute this
and understand it in in a more better
way
as you can see MySQL workbench has
started and for time being I've already
created a table employee which is having
column names as employee ID employee
name age designation date of birth city
that they belong to and salary and I've
chosen primary key as employee ID
because it uniquely identifies each and
every record in the table
now that we've created a table in order
to display all these records we have to
use this select statement ultimately so
to display all the values from each
column of the table that is the employee
table we have to write the following
query as select
star
from table name that is employee
let us execute this and see the output
as you can see it will display all the
values of the employees their employee
ID employee name is designation date of
birth the city and their respective
salaries
so if you want to display a particular
column so for that you have to write the
query as let's say if I want to select
employee ID employee name and the city
uh of the employees so for that I'll
write select
employee ID
comma
employee name
comma let's say I want to display the
salary so I'm taking a salary
from
table name
that is employee
let us execute this now
so as you can see only the employee ID
employee name and the salary of the
employees on the table are being shown
here because we have only specified a
particular column in this case
now similarly we can use where clause
also the where Clause is used with
select statement to return only those
rows from the table which satisfy the
specified condition in the query
for example uh if I want to show the
salary of the employee who is having uh
more than 30 000 so for that I'll write
the query as select
star
from employee
where
salary
is greater than 30 000.
so let us execute this statement and see
the output so as you can see it will
display the records of all those
employees who's having salary more than
30 000.
similarly you can see uh you can also
check
whether the city that they belong to is
Mumbai so for that we have to take the
SQL query as
select start from employee where city is
equals to suppose I want to display the
employee who belongs to the city Mumbai
so for that I'll take the city as Mumbai
and execute this statement
okay uh you have to mention Mumbai in uh
single quotes so that's the reason it is
showing error here
so let us now execute this and see the
output
so as you can see there are only two
employees who belong to the city uh that
is the employee kavya and Pavan who's
having the employee ID 103 and one not
nine so in this way you can use select
statement uh to display a particular uh
record by using work loss
now that we've got an idea on how SQL
select statement works let us now
discuss some select statement functions
the first one is Select
distinct
the select distinct in SQL is used to
fetch identical or distinct column
values from existing table without any
duplicate values now suppose in a
particular table there might be a higher
chance that there exists a duplicate
value and if you want to retrieve only
unique values in such scenario you use a
SQL listing statement I know it might be
a bit confusing so let me make it clear
to you guys uh consider the same
employee table again here
and uh if you look at the table
the values in the column City the
Hyderabad has been repeated more than
once here and not just Hyderabad Chennai
has also been repeated twice so in this
case in a broader sense if I just wanted
to know from which city the employee is
from I'll just use the distinct select
statement so using this uh
instead of multiple uh values that are
being displayed the SQL distance
statement make sure that the value is
retrieved only once and there is no room
for any repeated or distinct value so
let us now understand this syntax with
an example the syntax is followed as
select
distinct
now let's say if I want to fetch a
distinct designation of all the
employees of the company so for that I
am specifying the column name here as
designation
from the table that is employee
let us now execute this
uh there is a bit error in the code let
me just check it
foreign
so let us execute the query now and see
the output
so as you can see this is the output
that is being displayed where the unique
values
of the designation of all the employees
are being displayed that is business
analyst manager HR SD and so on so in
this way by using SQL select distinct
statement we can fetch distinct values
from the existing table
let us now discuss about select count
statement in SQL the select count is
used to get the total number of rows
from a table basically it Returns the
total number of Records present in the
database table let's take a simple
example consider the same employee table
now if you have a record in the table
and if you want to count the total
number of uh Records in the table for
that the following query would be
select
count
star
from the table name that is employee
let us execute this and see the output
now
so as you can see there are total 15
records present in the employee table
similarly you can use the where
condition as well if you want to get the
uh total number of rows uh of the
employees who are having salary equals
to 50 000 in the employee table so for
that the following query would be select
count
asterisk
from employee
specify the condition here now where
salary
is equals to fifty thousand
let us execute this statement now
so as you can see there are total three
employees who are having salary equals
to fifty thousand
similarly you can get the total number
of rows in a table by using the distinct
statement as well let's say if you want
to retrieve a unique count of the city
of the employees from the table the
following query would be select count
which is the keyword that we are using
and inside the bracket mentioned
distinct keyword
followed by the column name that is City
from the table that is employed
now let us execute this statement and
see the output
so as you can see there are total uh
eight employees who are belong to
different cities so in this way you can
use a select con statement to retrieve
various number of Records in a
particular table
next let us discuss about select top or
limit
statement in SQL the select top
statement in SQL shows The Limited
number of Records or rows from the
database table the top clause in the
statement specifies how many rows we
want to display from our table this
Clause is used when there are thousands
of Records stored in the database table
now all database systems do not support
top keyword now as far as MySQL is
concerned it supports the limit keyword
so let us now look at the syntax of
Select limit statement the syntax is
followed as
select
star
from
employee table
limit is the keyword that we have to use
and I want to display the first three
records of the employees so I'm
specifying three here
so let us execute this statement
so as you can see the first three
records of the employees who are having
ID employee ID as one not one one or two
one or three are being displayed
let us consider another scenario here if
you want to fix the first three
employees who got highest salaries from
the employee table then the following
query would be
select
star
from
the table name that is employee
ordered by
is the condition that I am using to
display the employee details
salary
desc that means descending now I want to
display the records in the descending
order and I am limiting the value up to
2.
limit three
so let us execute the statement now
so as you can see it will display a
total of three Records who are having
the salary uh who got the highest salary
in the descending order that is Kamal
who got the salary as 60 000 Sindhu
having 50 000 and Kiran who is having 50
000. so in this way you can use limit
statement to display the specified rows
that is the top rows in the table
next let us discuss about select random
statement in SQL as the name suggests
SQL select random statement is used to
return a random Row from a table present
in the database it has many real life
applications for example if a HR manager
wants to send uh 10 random mails to his
employees then he can use random
function in SQL to send the email it is
also used to display random questions
during an online exams for students so
the syntax for select random is followed
as
select
column name now I want to display the
records of all the employees so I am
choosing star operator
from the table that is employee
order by is the conditional Clause we
have to use
followed by that we have to mention Rand
which is the function
let us execute the statement
so as you can see the details of the
employees are being displayed in a mixed
manner that is they are displayed in a
random way as you can see the employee
details of employee who is having ID 1
114 is being displayed your first and
then 1 12 and then one for note 3. so in
this way you can display the values
randomly using random function in SQL
similarly you can limit the values as
well if you want to show the top three
random values of the employees you can
use limit statement here so limit
and if I want to display the first four
records of the employees so I'm choosing
four
let us execute the statement now
so it will show the details of the
employees randomly up to uh four that is
the top four details of the employees so
in this way you can use a random
statement to display uh random values
within a database table
next let us discuss about select in
statement in SQL the select in function
is used to fetch specific rows or values
from an existing table with multiple
conditions the conditions are specified
within Clause the operation of Select in
is same as R operation select in is used
to reduce the multiple or operators in
select statement let us understand this
with an example so if I want if I see
details of employees who are having
employee ID as let's say one or two or
one not four or one or seven from the
employee table then the following query
would be select
star
from the table that is employee
where
employee ID
now we have to mention the in keyword
here and within the brackets mention the
IDS so I am taking one or two
or not 4
and 1.7
so let us execute this statement and see
the output
so as you can see it is displaying the
values of the employees who are having
ID either one or two or one not four or
one not seven
next let us discuss about select date
statement in SQL SQL select date is used
to retrieve the values of date from a
database if you want to find a
particular date from a database you can
use this statement so let us understand
with an example let's say if you want to
display the records of all those
employees who are born before 1995 Jan
first so the following query would be
select
star
from the table that is employee
where
date of birth
is less than
Jan first
make sure you incorporate the date in
the single quotes otherwise it will
throw an error so let me execute this
statement
so as you can see it is displaying the
records of all those employees who are
born before 1995 Jan first similarly you
can use uh greater than operator as well
to show the employees who are born after
1995. similarly uh if you want to fetch
the employees who have bond between a
particular date let's say who are born
between 1996 and 1998 then the foreign
query would be select start from
employee where date of birth
between is the keyword we have to use
between let's say I'm using
1996 Jan first
and 1998.
1998 Jan first
so let me execute this statement and see
the output
so as you can see it is displaying the
records of all those employees who are
born in between uh the particular date
that we have given that is in between
1996 and 1998. so in this way you can
use the select date statement to
retrieve the date values in the database
next let us discuss about select some
statement in SQL select sum is used to
return the sum of all the values in a
specified column now you have to make a
note here that some sum function is
applied only on numeric or numeric
related fields let us consider the same
employee table again and if you want to
get the sum of all the employee salaries
in the employee table then the following
query would be select
sum as the keyword and within the
brackets mentioned the salary column
from the table that is
employee
let us execute the statement and see the
output
so as you can see it is showing the sum
of the service of all the employees here
that is 6 lakh 5000 is the total value
of the combined salary of all the
employees similarly you can use the
where condition here as well uh to get
the sum of the salaries of employee by
specifying a condition let's say if I
want to get the total salary of all
those employees who belong to the city
uh Mumbai so for that I am writing the
query as select some salary from
employee where is the conditional clause
City
equals to Mumbai
make sure Mumbai is in single coach
otherwise it will throw an error so let
us execute the statement now and see the
output
so as you can see it is displaying the
sum of all the salaries of those
employees belonging to Mumbai as 80 000.
so in this way you can use the uh some
select sum statement in SQL to display
the sum of values in a particular column
and finally let us now look at the
select null statement in SQL null in a
table represents that the field has no
value these null values are used to
represent the missing data in a
particular table now a null value is
different from a zero value that means a
field with a null value is the one that
has been left blank during the record
creation Now to verify the column value
is null or not we can use the keyword
ease null or is not null now we should
make a note here that null value can't
compare with operators like equals to
greater than or less than so let us take
an example to understand the syntax now
if you want to fetch the details of the
students uh whose marks Arnel that means
the marks that they have scored in the
final exam are yet to be assigned to the
students so for that the following query
would be
uh select
select
star
from the table that is student
where is the condition
marks
is null which is the keyword we are
using so let us execute this statement
and see the output
so as you can see there are two students
whose marks are yet to be updated and it
also means that their marks are not
equals to zero it's simply that their
marks have been left out and kept as
null for the tutorial by understanding
what SQL Clauses next we'll go through
different types of SQL Clauses and
finally we'll discuss about SQL where
clause and execute MySQL workbench
what is SQL Clause SQL Clause are
basically inbuilt SQL functions that use
a certain conditional expression which
helps to access a particular set of
records from the database table Clauses
help us to restrict and manage the data
using valid constraints on the data in
our database now since we have large
amounts of data stored in the database
we use Clauses to query the table to get
the desired data only so the complexity
is reduced when condition is applied to
an SQL statement
SQL Clauses use filters and analyzes the
data quickly because it is used to
extract only those records that fulfill
the specified condition
types of SQL Clauses SQL Clauses are
divided into three types the first one
is the basic clause which uses a
condition the second one is order by
which is used to sort the data in tables
in either ascending or descending order
and the last one is Group by which is
used for organizing similar data into
groups
SQL where Clause SQL where Clause is the
most used and integral part of any query
to specify a condition in the SQL
statement which retrieves only those
records which satisfy the given
condition the where Clause is not only
used in the select statement but it is
also used in the update delete statement
Etc using logical and comparison
operators like greater than less than
and equal to operators let us now look
at the syntax of where Clause the syntax
is followed as select column 1 column 2
and up to n number of columns from table
name where condition here column and
column 2 represents the columns which we
want to fetch the data from the table
and the condition here represents the
required condition to fetch rows based
on the requirement it contains column
name operator user defined value
comparison and logical operators are
also used in this condition
so in this way we can use where clause
let us now execute some statement which
uses where clause in MySQL workbench
as you can see the MySQL workbench has
started and before we write queries
using a wire Clause we have to first
create a table so I have created a table
here employee which is columns employee
ID employee name age destination date of
birth the city they belong to and their
salary and I've taken primary key here
as employee ID because it uniquely
identifies each and every record in the
table
now that we've created the table let us
now look at the simple and basic query
using the where Clause now let's say if
I want to display the details of all
those employees who belong to the city
Mumbai so for that the following query
would be select
star
from the table that is employee
now we have to mention the condition
that is the where Clause where
City
is equals to Mumbai
mention Mumbai in single quotes
otherwise it will show an error so let
us now execute this statement and see
the output
now when you execute the statement it
will show me the output of two employees
who belong to the city so let us now
take another example now we'll use the
greater than operator using the where
Clause now let's say if I want to
display the details of all those
employees whose salary is greater than
30 000 so for that the following query
would be select star
from table that is employee
where
salary is greater than 30 000.
so let us execute the statement
now when we execute the statement it
will show me the records of all those
employees who are having salary more
than 30 000 now I think here we have
around uh
15 since we have 15 records in the table
we have a total of eight employees whose
salary is more than thirty thousand so
in this way you can use a greater than
operator similarly you can use the less
than operator as well and let us see the
output
whose salary is less than 35 000 will
take 35 000 here
and now see the output
so there are uh total three employees
who are having the salary less than 35
000 that is uh Aryan Preeti Akil who are
having salary as thirty thousand so in
this way you can use less than operator
as well now let us make another scenario
now if I want to mention a range of
salaries of how much they earn let's say
if I want to display the records of all
those employees who are earning salary
between 35 000 and 50 000. so for that
the following query would be select
star
from the table
that is employee
where
salary
between is the keyword we have to use
here
35 000
and
50 000.
let us now execute this statement and
see the output
so now these are all the uh records of
the employees who are having salary in
between 35 000 and 15 000. so in this
way you can use uh various comparison
operators to perform uh queries using
where Clause similarly uh you can also
update the values in the table as well
using the update command let's say if I
want to update the salary of employee
whose employee ID is uh one not four so
for that the following query would be
update
table name that is employee
set is the keyword we have to use here
salary
now I want to change the salary as 25
000 so I am choosing twenty five
thousand
specify the condition where
employee ID is equals to uh one not six
so let us execute the statement and see
the output
so as you can see our query successfully
implemented and the employee who ID 106
who's having salary like before some he
used to have some salary now his salary
is changed into 25 000. so let us see
whether it is changed or not we'll use
the select command again to display the
details of all the employees so for that
the query will be select star
from the table that is employed
let us now execute the statement
so 106 uh employee name is varsha who's
working as a software developer and
salary has been changed to 25 000 so in
this way you can use where Clause to
perform various operations using certain
conditions
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skillup by simply learn click
on the link in the description to know
more
now that we have understood how to write
a query using the where condition let us
now look at some other conditional
statements which uses where Clause first
let us discuss about SQL and condition
SQL and condition is used to specify
multiple condition in where clause and
condition basically Returns the rows or
those values that satisfies both the
conditions that are written after the
where clause in simple terms we can say
that it will only return those values
when both the conditions are met let us
now understand this with an example
let's say if I want to access the
records of all those employees whose
designation is business analyst and
their salary is 35 000. for that the
following query would be select
star
from the table that is employee
where I am specifying the condition here
designation
is equals to
business analyst
and
is the keyword that we have to specify
here
salary
is equals to 35 000.
let us execute the statement now
so as you can see it is displaying the
records of two employees whose
designation is business analyst and
their salary is 35 000 but if you look
at the uh employee table carefully let
me just display the values uh there is
the employee ID 101 Who belongs to the
designation business analyst and
similarly we have another employee who's
employed is one not nine and whose
employed is 111 here we have three
records but instead it is displaying
only three or two records that's because
there's an employee ID 109 who's having
Who belongs to the designation business
analyst that is having forty thousand so
in this case he is not meeting the other
condition that is why it is being
displayed only two values
so in this way you can use and statement
to filter the records from the table let
us now look at the next statement that
is R SQL or condition is used to specify
again the same multiple conditions in
where clause which is used to fetch the
rows or values which satisfy any of the
condition now unlike uh and statement if
any of the condition that is provided is
true then it will return all those
values so let me just uh
execute this with an uh example let's
say if I want to access the records of
all those employees whose designation is
manager and the city that they belong to
is Chennai so for that I'll write the
query as select star
from the table that is
employee
where
designation
is equals to manager
or
the city that they belong to is Chennai
so let me just execute this statement
and see the output
so when execute this statement it will
show a total of three records of all
those employees whose designation is
either manager or the city that they
belong to is Chennai now we have uh the
records of employee who belongs to City
Bangalore indoor as well but it is
showing here because the designation is
manager that is here it is satisfying
either one of the condition that is
either the designation that is manager
or the city that they belong to is
Chennai so in this way you can use our
statement to filter the records
next let us discuss about the limit
condition in SQL the limit condition is
used to fetch those records that have
only limited number of values let's say
if I want to access the records of first
five employees from the table then I'll
write the following query as select star
from the table that is employee
now you have to mention the keyword
limit
now I want to access the records of
first five employees so I am specifying
5 as the condition here so let me
execute this statement so it will
display the first five records of the
employees from the employee table now
this limit condition is used like when
you have thousands of Records in a table
and if you want to access the first 100
records of the employees then you can
use the limit condition here with the
example
next let us discuss about SQL as
condition statement now SQL as condition
is used to rename a column temporarily
in a given table now in simple words we
can say that SQL as keyword is used to
give an alias name to the table or
column name in the query and in this way
we can increase the readability and
understandability of the query and call
and also the column headings in the
table so let us understand with an
example let's say if I want to change
the column name of salary to the total
salary then I would write the following
query as select
salary
as
within the single quotes mention the new
column name that is total salary
from the table that is employed
so let us execute this statement and see
the output
so as you can see salary has been
changed into a total salary in this way
you can use the and condition statement
to change the column of the table
temporarily
and finally let us discuss the like
statement in SQL the like condition
statement is used to fetch matching rows
or values from the table that satisfies
the wildcard operator now the Wild Card
operator in SQL uh basically have two
types the first one is percentage sign
the percentage sign represents a single
or multiple character and the second one
is underscore underscore represents a
single number or character now you might
be a bit confused here so let me just
explain with an example let's say if you
want to access the records of all those
employees whose name starts with k so
for that I'll write the query as select
star from the table that is employee now
specify the condition where
employee name
like is the keyword we have to use here
and within the single quotes now we are
displaying the records of employees
whose name starts with k right so I am
taking K and mention the percentage
symbol
so let us execute this statement and see
the output
foreign
details of all those employees whose
name starts with k so there are total uh
three employees in the table whose name
starts with care similarly if you want
to display the records of those
employees whose name ends with a so for
that we have to mention percentage a so
let me just execute this statement and
see the output
so it will display the values of all
those employees whose name is ending
with the letter A so there are total uh
five employees in the table whose name
is ending with a so in this way you can
use the like operator which also uses
the where clause so if you want to
upskill yourself in the field of data
analytics and become proficient in SQL
and database management then our
postgraduate program in data analytics
in partnership with Purdue University
and in collaboration with IBM can help
you with that this course features
master classes and follows an applied
learning model designed with real life
projects and business case studies which
will help you boost your career so what
are you waiting for enroll now and take
advantage of this amazing opportunity
you can find the course Link in the
description box below
start the tutorial by understanding what
is SQL order by and then we'll discuss
the syntax of SQL order by and finally
we look at some order by statements and
execute them in MySQL workbench
so what is order by Clause the SQL order
by Clause allows you to sort the results
of a query based on a specific column or
group of columns that means it helps you
to reorder the data that is present in
the tables in one or more columns now
this sorting can be either ascending or
descending order let us now understand
the syntax of SQL order by Clause the
syntax is followed as SQL select column
1 column 2 up to n number of columns
from table name where condition order by
column AC or DAC so let me just explain
the syntax the column specified after
the order by keyword specifies the name
of the columns that are used to sort
data and after that we use two keywords
that is AC to represent the data in
ascending manner or dese to represent
the data in descending order
now the reason for using the order by
Claus is that the order that the data
shows in a database table is completely
random and sometimes this might not be
the order in which you would like to see
when we run our queries in the database
so for that purpose we use order by
Clause now that we've understood what
the SQL order by Clauses let us jump
into the execution part
as you can see MySQL workbench has
started and on the left side you can
view the database simply code which has
two tables that is employee and student
we are going to work on the employee
table now so first let me display the
records of all the employee details
present in the employee table for that I
am going to use this select statement
select star
from the table name that is employee
let me just execute this statement
so it will show me the results of
details of all the employees with their
employee ID employee name age
destination date of birth CT they belong
to and the salary they have so let us
just understand the basic query of order
by Clause now so the syntax is followed
as select
star
from the table that is employee
order by
salary
now this is a basic statement related to
order Y and let us execute this so it
will display the output and in a
particular order of the salary and if
you look at carefully it is displaying
in the uh ascending order now if no
keyword is specified after the column
based on which we have sorted the
records in a table the Sorting will be
done by default in ascending order so
with that uh that brings us to the to
our first order by statement that is
order by ascending
statement now the order by ascending
statement is used to sort the data in
ascending order so let us consider
another example here now if I want to
fetch the details of all the employees
uh and their employee names in ascending
order for that the following query would
be select
star
from the table that is employee
order by
employee name and mention the keyword
ASC
so let us execute this statement and see
the output so it will display the
results uh the employee names in the
ascending order that is in alphabetical
order starting from aakash
and up until V so in this way you can
use the order by ascending statement to
display all your records in ascending
manner
similarly you can specify the where
condition here as well
let's say if I want to fetch the details
of all the employees from the employee
table in ascending order of their uh
employee name whose age is greater than
26. so for that the following query
would be so let's start from employee
where age greater than 26 order by
employee name as an ASC so let me
execute this statement so it will
display the records of all those
employees whose age is more than 26 and
it will it will sort the data of
employee names in ascending order
so in this way you can use the order by
ascending
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skill up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
now let us discuss about order by
descending statement the order by
descending statement is used to sort the
data in the descending order let us
understand this with an example let's
say if I want to display the details of
all the employees from the employee
table in descending order of their
salaries for that the following query
would be select star
from the table that is employee
order by
salary
and mention the keyword Des
so let us execute this statement and see
the output
so this will be the following output
wherein it will show the salaries of all
the employees in the descending order
that is from highest to lowest in this
case the first employee who is having
the highest salary is 65 000 and up
until the lowest salary 25 000. also
similarly you can specify the wear
condition here also so if you want to
display the details of employees whose
employee ID is greater than let's say
one or six and want to sort their sales
and descending order for that I'll use
the query as select start from employee
so mention the keyword where
employee ID
greater than
106.
so let us execute this statement and see
the output
so it will display the records of all
those employees uh who's having employee
more than one or six and it will sort
the data of this salary is in descending
order that is from highest lowest again
so in this way you can use the order by
descending statement to display all your
requests present in the table in an
ascending manner
let us now discuss the next order by
statement that is SQL order by random
and as well as limit statements the
order by random statement is used to
display the records uh present in the
table randomly and the Syntax for the
order by Randomness select
star
from the table that is employee
order by mention the keyword
random is the function we are using here
so we have to mention r a n d
and let us execute the statement now so
it will display the records present in
the table in an in a random order
similarly we also have a limit statement
which is used to display only a specific
number of columns in the database table
so let us now look at the syntax of
order by limit
now let's say if I want to fetch the
first uh six employee details from the
table in descending order of their
salaries so the following query would be
select star
from employee
order by
salary I want to display the salaries
and descending order so I'm specifying
the desc keyword
and uh I'm limit I'm using the limit
function here
so let us display the output of this
query
so it will show me the random uh six
details of the employees in order of
their salaries from highest to lowest
that is in a descending order so in this
way you can also use order by random and
limit statement in your SQL queries
and finally let us now discuss about the
order by multiple statement in SQL till
now we have discussed only how to uh
fetch the records from only a single
table and sort them out but you can
fetch the rows by sorting multiple rows
in either ascending or descending order
using order by multiple statement so let
us understand this is an example let's
say if you want to fetch the details of
all the employees from the table in
ascending order of the designation as
well as descending order of their salary
then the following query would be select
star
from employee
order by
so we're taking the designation as
ascending order so designation
mention the keyword ASC
comma
unless salary
in descending manner so let us display
the uh
statement
so as you can see it will display the
designation in ascending order that is
business analyst and then customer care
data analyst HR and so on and their
respective salaries in descending form
so in this way you can fetch the data
from multiple rows using the multiple
statement in SQL firstly we'll start the
tutorial by understanding what is SQL
insert and then we'll understand the
syntax of SQL insert statement and
finally we'll go through some of the SQL
insert statements and execute them in
MySQL workbench
so what is SQL insert statement SQL
insert statement is widely used command
in SQL which is a part of data
manipulation language DML used by
various relational databases the insert
command is used for inserting one or
more rows into a database table with
specified table column values let us now
understand the Syntax for insert
statement
now we have two types of syntaxes the
first method is insert into table name
values and within the brackets you have
to mention the values in this first
method there is no need to specify the
column names where the data will be
inserted you need to only insert their
values the second method specifies both
the column name and the values which you
want to insert and the syntax is insert
into which is the keyword we are using
after that we have to mention the table
name and within the brackets we have to
mention the columns and then values
values one values two values three and
so on up to our requirement so this was
the syntax let us take an example now
let's say I've created a table students
and I want to insert values into it so
the Syntax for inserting the values is
insert into table name I am taking here
it as students and I'm mentioning The
Columns row number name age City and I
mean inserting the values as roll number
as 1 name as Rohan age as 22 and CTS
Hyderabad so in this way you can insert
values up to n number of rows into your
table
so now that we've understood and got an
idea of what SQL insert statement is let
us jump into MySQL workbench and do the
execution part choose from over 300
in-demand skills and get access to 1000
plus hours of video content for free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
as you can see MySQL workbench has
started and
in order to
create a table and the syntax is
followed as create table which is the
keyword that we use and I am creating a
new table that is customer and which is
column names as customer ID customer
name their age address the product they
have purchased and the purchase date of
the product and I'm taking primary key
here as customer ID because it uniquely
identifies each and every record so let
me just use the select statement to
display whether the table is created or
not select star
from the table that is customer
so as you can see our table is
successfully created with the column
names that we have specified
now that we've created a table let us
see how to insert the values into it for
that first let us discuss the insert
into value statement the insert into
value statement is used to insert either
all the column values or a specified
number of column values in the table
inserting only specified column data in
the row requires the column name should
be specified in the insert statement so
let's say if I want to insert all the
columns into the customer table the
following query would be
insert
into
table name which is the customer
now within the uh brackets we have to
mention the column names so the columns
that we have taken are customer ID
customer name
their age
address
product that they've purchased
and the purchase date
close the brackets now mention the
values keyword and again within the
brackets specify the values for each of
the columns so I'm taking a customer ID
as let's say 1011
comma customer name let's say Rahul
now make sure you uh mention the
character values inside the single
quotes and for integer values you need
not mention the single quotes
next there is let's say 25
comma address let's say the
City they belong to is the address so
I'm taking you know as Hyderabad
comma makes the product that they have
purchased let's say they have let's say
rival has purchased the phone as the
product
and finally purchased it uh let's say
March
March and let's take date as uh 25.
so close the brackets and
put this semicolon so let us execute
this statement and see
so as you can see our query has been
successfully executed now to display the
values I'll use the select command again
so let us execute the statement so as
you can see the values have been
successfully inserted into our table
with respect to their columns as
customer ID customer name age address
product and the purchase date
so here we've inserted a row with all
the column values using the insert
statement similarly you can insert a row
with only specified columns values as
well let's say if you want to insert
data for only the columns customer ID
customer name and the product they have
purchased and leaving the rest of the
columns as such the following query
would be
insert
into
table name
mention the table name that is customer
and within the brackets mention the
columns that you want to enter the
values so I'm only entering the values
for customer ID
customer name
and the product that they have purchased
and mentioned the uh keyword values
open the brackets and specify the values
as accordingly so I'm taking uh customer
IDs
thousand and uh 12 customer name let's
say kavya
and the product that they've purchased
is let's say uh as AC
close the brackets mention the
semicolon and let us execute the
statement
so as you can see our query is
successfully executed so let me display
the values and I'll use the select
statement to display the values so as
you can see only the customer ID
customer name and the product that
they've purchased is being displayed
here and leaving the rest of the columns
that is age address and the purchase
date as null values so in this way you
can also insert values into only the
specified uh Columns of the table next
let us discuss about insert multiple row
statement we can insert multiple rows in
a single insert statement at a time we
can insert multiple row values by
grouping row values with open and close
brackets and separating each row with a
comma Now if you want to insert let's
say hundreds of records and insert
values into it it will take a lot of
time and it in the at the same time it
will become hectic if you specify the
column names each and every time so in
order to reduce that and insert the
values quickly we use this multiple
statement
so let's say if I want to insert uh new
values insert two rows of employee ID
1013 and 1014 so the following query
would be insert
into
customer that is the table name and
within the brackets uh
so before enter any values you have to
mention the keyword values
and you can directly enter the values
now without mentioning the column names
so as you can see I've inserted two rows
and the data into into the table so let
me just execute the statement and let us
see the output
so I said our query has been
successfully executed uh let me use the
select statement to display the new
values
so as you can see the customer ID 2013
and 2014 details uh has been displayed
so in this way you can use the uh
insert multiple statement to insert uh
multiple rows into the table so just
keep a note that make sure you insert
the values accordingly in the order of
the columns that you have taken in the
table press session we'll start the
tutorial by understanding what is SQL
update and then let us understand the
syntax of SQL update statement and
finally we look at some of the SQL
update statements and execute them in
MySQL workbench
so what is my SQL update statement SQL
update statement is used to update the
column values in the existing table that
means it is used to change the values
present in one or more rows in an
existing table now where Clause is used
in the update statement to update the
Matched rows that satisfy this condition
that we have specified in the where
Clause let us understand the syntax of
SQL update statement the syntax is
followed as update which is the keyword
followed by that we have to mention the
table name and then set column name is
equals to new value that is the value
that you want to change from the
previous value and after that you have
to mention the condition that is where
specify the condition to understand this
in a better way let us take an example
consider a table student which is having
columns roll number name age and city
now if I want to update the value of
City uh of the student who's having roll
number S3 from Mumbai to Chennai so the
following query would be update student
which is the table name set city is
equals to Chennai where roll number is
equals to 3. now if we execute this
statement this will be the output where
the city which is uh previously Mumbai
has been changed into Chennai so in this
way you can use the update statement now
that we've got an idea on what a SQL
update statement is and how it works let
us jump into MySQL workbench for the
execution part
as you can see MySQL workbench has
started and on the left side we can view
the tables that are present in our
database simply code so I'm going to
work on the employee table so let me
just display the records that are
present in the table for that I'll use
the select command select star
from the table that is employee so let
us execute the statement so it will
display the values of all the details of
the employees having their employee ID
employee name is the designation date of
birth city and salary now let us look at
the update statement first now if I want
to update the salary of the employee
who's having employee ID as let's say
106 to 35
000 now initially the employee ID 106
the employees having the salary 25000
now if I want to change into 30 000 the
following query would be update
table name that is employee
use the keyword set
mention the column name that you want to
change now we are changing the salary
set salary equals to from 25 000 to I'm
changing into 35 000.
where
employee ID equals to 1.6
so let us execute this statement and see
the output
so as you can see our statement is
successfully executed now let us use the
select command to display the records
so as you can see the employee ID uh 106
is having the salary as 135 000 it is
being now changed into 35 000 from 25
000 so in this way you can use the
update statement similarly uh you can
update multiple column values as well
let's say if I want to update the
designation and the salary of the
employee based on their employee ID for
that the following query would be
update
table name employee
set designation
now if I want to change the designation
of the employee lohith who's having the
employee ID one or three from HR to
senior HR
so I'll mention senior HR
as our new value
and also I want to change the salary so
put a comma
salary equals to let's say I want to
change the salary from 45 000 to 60 000.
where mention the condition
employee ID equals to uh one not three
so let us execute the statement and see
the output
so our query has been successfully
executed so as you can see the employee
name lohith who's having employed a one
or three his designation has been
changed to senior HR and his salary has
also been changed into sixty thousand so
in this way you can use uh update
statement to change multiple values that
are present in the uh columns as well
next let us discuss about update date
statement in SQL update date statement
is used to update the date and time
values in the existing table uh all the
data a date and time value should be
specified in this single quotes and you
can also mention the condition using the
where plus let's take an example let's
say if I want to update the date of
birth of the employees uh who is having
employee ID 104 so the following query
would be
update
table name employee
set date of birth
now I am changing the date of birth of
the employee uh ID who's a 103 so I'm
changing the date of birth as 1996 Jan
first
mention the condition where
employee ID equals to 103.
so let us execute the statement and see
the output
so our query has been successfully
executed now in the resultant uh table
you can see the date of birth of the
employee who's having employed is one or
three has been changed to 1996 January
1st in this way you can use the update
date statement to change the date values
let us take another example now if you
can also update multiple rows present in
the table let's say if you want to
update the date of joining of all those
employees who's having the designation
business analyst for that the following
query would be update
table name that is employee
set
date of joining
equals to uh I'm taking the date of
joining as uh first January 2022.
first January
now specify the condition where
designation
equals to
business analyst
put a semicolon and execute this
statement now
so let us see the output
whether the values are changed or not as
you can see uh the date of joining for
all the business analysts that are
present in the table for example uh for
the employee ID one not one
as well as 109 and 111 their date of
joining has been changed to uh Jan
January 1st 2022. in this way you can
use the update a date statement to
change the values of date and time that
are present in the table
we'll start the tutorial by
understanding what SQL delete statement
is and then we'll understand the syntax
of SQL delete statement and finally we
look at some SQL delete statements and
execute them in MySQL workbench
so what is SQL delete statement SQL
delete statement is one of the data
manipulation command DML that is used to
remove rows from a table that means you
will able to delete the existing records
from the table now you can either delete
a single row multiple rows or values
from the existing table depending on the
condition that is specified that means
this statement with where condition is
used to delete the rows that satisfies
the condition with where clause and the
remaining rows are not changed also
delete statement without where condition
is used to delete all the rows from the
table let us now understand the syntax
of SQL direct statement the syntax is
followed as delete from table name where
condition here where condition is
optional that means you can either use
it or you cannot use it
so let us take an example let's say if I
want to delete uh the details of the
employee from the employee table whose
employee ID is 101 so for that the
following syntax would be delete from
employee where employee ID equals to 1.1
now if you execute this query it will
delete the details of that employee
who's having employed yes or not one in
this way you can use delete statement to
delete one or more rows from the
existing table now that we've got an
idea on what SQL delete is let us jump
directly into the MySQL workbench and
get into the execution part as you can
see MySQL workbench has started and on
the left side you can view the various
tables that are present in our database
simply code so let us consider uh
employee table first as an example table
to frame SQL queries to perform various
operations using the delete statement
firstly uh so let me display the values
that are present in the employee table
for that I am using the select statement
select star from the table that is
employee
so let me just execute this statement so
it will display the records of all the
employees their employee ID employee
name is destination date of birth city
and salary
so firstly uh let us see how to delete a
single Row from the given existing table
for that let me take an example let's
say if I want to delete one of the
employee details uh from the employee
table whose employee ID is let's say one
not eight for that the following query
would be
delete
from
table name that is employee
where specify the condition
employee ID
equals to 107.
so let us execute the statement and see
the output
so our query has been successfully
executed let me use the select statement
to display the records and see whether
or not our record is deleted or not so
as you can clearly see uh 107 uh record
of the employee is missing from the
table that means we have successfully
deleted the record of that employee
who's having employee 107.
let us now understand how to delete
multiple rows from the existing table
before that let me display the total
number of Records present in the table
so that we will have a clear idea on how
many records have been deleted after
executing the query for that I am using
a count statement select count
foreign
use the star operator
from the table that is employee
so we have total 14 records in the table
so let us now execute this statement uh
for that we will take an example let's
say if I want to delete multiple
employee details from the employee table
whose designation is let's say business
analyst so for that the following query
would be delete from
table that is employee
where
designation
equals to business analyst
[Music]
so let us execute the statement and see
the output
so as you can see our query has been
successfully executed let us again use
the account statement to see the values
that are deleted
so as you can see the total count of the
employees in the table has been changed
to 11 that means there are total of
three employees whose designation as
business analyst and since we have
specified the condition where we want to
delete only those records from the table
whose designation is business analyst so
in this way you can delete multiple rows
by using the where condition statement
now similarly you can delete multiple
records from the table using multiple
conditions as well this can be done
using various operators like and or
between
Etc so let us take an example for that
uh suppose let's say if I want to delete
the employee details from the employee
table uh whose designation is let's say
data analyst and their salary is less
than 30 000 by using or operator for
that the following query would be
delete
from table that is employee
specify the condition where
designation
equals to data analyst
or
their salary
is less than 30 000.
so let us execute this statement now
so our query has been successfully
executed and let us see the output for
that I am using the select count
statement as well again
so as you can see only one record has
been deleted from the table that means
there is only a record of the employee
whose designation is either data analyst
or their salary is less than 30 000 so
in this way you can use uh multiple
conditions to delete the records from
table as well
let us now take another scenario let's
say if I want to delete a multiple
employee retails from the employee table
whose salary is in between let's say 30
000 and 45
000 for that I'll use the between
operator and the following query would
be delete
from the table employee
where
salary
between
is the operator that we have to use 30
and 45 000.
so let us execute this statement and see
the output
so our query has been successfully
executed let me use the count statement
to display the number of Records now so
as you can see previously we had uh 10
records in the table now it has been
changed to four that means a total of
six records has been deleted from the
table wherein uh the salary of the
employees uh ranging between thirty
thousand and forty five thousand so in
this way you can use the uh Delete
statement to delete multiple records
from the table by specifying the
multiple conditions
now we have seen how to delete a single
record or multiple or records or even
multiple records using multiple
conditions in the existing table
sometimes there might be a requirement
to delete the entire table data to free
up the memory or to allocate new data
into the table for that we use the
delete statement to delete the uh hold
records from the table as well for that
executing delete statement without the
where Clause delete the entire table
data so make sure you are careful while
using the delete statement because
you'll end up deleting the whole table
if you are using a without where Clause
let's say if I want to delete the
remaining records of the table from the
employee table I'll simply write the
query as delete
from table that is employee so let me
execute this statement and see the
output our query has been successfully
uh executed so let me just display the
records uh in the table for that I'll
use the select statement so as you can
see only the columns are being present
but their records that were present in
these columns have been completely
deleted uh using the delete statement so
in this way you can delete uh all the
records from the table without
specifying the condition using the where
Clause column operations play an
important role because for even for data
analysis or even if you're performing
queries on your database table it is
quite essential because let's say for
instance you have created a table as per
required with requirement with a set of
different columns now later at a
different stage you might need to add
some additional requirements where the
table might need to have some additional
columns or even some columns might
require to be deleted or some column
names need to be changed into a new
columns within that existing table now
there are mainly two different ways to
satisfy this condition first is you have
to delete the table and recreate a new
table as per your new requirement now
this is possible and advice only when
the table is empty right now if the
table is not empty you have to copy the
data and then delete the table or create
another table and then copy or load the
data into the new table now this is time
consuming and also not advisable the
other way is to add delete or modify the
columns and the data present in it to
the current Table without touching the
existing columns and its corresponding
data now this is done by using the alter
table statement which fulfills the
requirement of adding new data within
the existing columns now the alter table
statement is used to change the
structure of the existing table by
adding deleting or modifying The Columns
without modifying the data in it
so let us discuss what are the different
operations that are performed in SQL
firstly let us discuss the add column
operation in SQL
so for that let me consider the employee
table so let me just display the values
in it select star
from employee
so as you can see uh the employee table
has various columns like employee ID
employee name age designation City
salary date of joining Department ID
now let's say I have an additional
requirement where I want to add another
column let's say if I want to add the
other number details of the employees
for that I'll use the alter statement
and the query is Alter
table
employee
add column
aadhar number
and mentioned the column data type I am
taking varker
and we'll specify not null as our
constraint that means uh it must have a
other number for every employee in the
table
so let me just execute the statement so
as you can see our query has been
successfully executed so let me just
display the values
so as you can see uh there is a new
column other number that has been
created in our existing table without
disrupting any columns and its values in
the uh employee table
now similarly you can add multiple
columns to your existing table as well
and the query is Alter table
employee
add column
and within the brackets mention the
different column names now let's say if
I want to add the path number as well as
the um that is the universal account
number of the employees so the query
will be add column
pan number
mention the column data type I'm taking
marker again
comma
uan number
mention the data type
as what care
so let us execute the statement and see
the output
so our query has been executed
successfully let us see the output now
so as you can see uh we have two other
columns part number and UN number in our
employee table since we have not
mentioned mentioned any constraints here
as null or not null so it by default it
is taking here as null values so in this
way you can use the alter table command
to add multiple columns in your table as
well
now similarly you can even modify or
update the column values as well let's
say if I want to update the existing
column name into a new name now for that
I'll use the alter table statement again
now consider the employee table again so
let me just display the values
[Music]
now if I want to change the salary
column name into total salary so for
that the following query would be alter
table
employee
change column is the keyword we use in
MySQL so mention the keyword change
column so we want to change the salary
column into total salary
and also mention the data type as well
so let us execute the query and see the
output
so our query has been successfully
executed so let me just display the
records again so as you can see a salary
name of the column salary has been
changed into the total salary here
so in this way you can update the column
values as well now similarly you can
also modify the existing uh column type
in the table as well for that the
following query would be alter table
employee
modify is the keyword
now let's say if I want to change the
age data type so let's see what the
initial or the previous data type was in
for age so I'll use the describe
employee
query here
so we basically have VAR care as our
data type for the age now if I want to
change into int so I'll just basically
uh mention the in keyword here
so let us execute this statement and see
the output
so there was a bit error I forgot to
mention the column keyword here so
that's how it is showing an error so let
me just again uh describe the table
employee so as you can see the data type
of the age column has been changed from
barcap to int so in this way you can use
the alter table to modify the column
data type as well
now similarly we can also uh modify a
new column or an existing column with a
default value as well let's say I want
to take a new column uh bonus that is
the bonus salary for all the employees
so for that the following query would be
alter table
employee
alter column is the keyword we use here
bonus is the column that I'm creating
set default
is the keyword and I'm keeping the bonus
salary default as let's say 15 000.
so let us execute the query and see the
output
so I forgot to add the column of the
bonus so let me just first add the
column so altar table employee add
column bonus
20.
so our bonus column has been
successfully created here
so now we can see our query will be
successful here as well
so let me just describe the table again
now if you scroll down you can see the
bonus column uh the field which it has
the default salary as fifteen thousand
so in this way you can add the default
value to your existing columns or to
your new columns as well
and finally we can also drop the columns
uh the drop column is basically is used
to delete the unnecessary or unwanted
columns in our database so let's say if
I want to delete the create already
created a
columns such as aadhar pan uan on bonus
so I'll use the drop statement here to
delete the columns that were created
earlier so drop
so the query would be alter table
employee
drop column now first let us delete a
single column here so let's say if I
want to delete the other number column
so I'll use the other number column here
so let us see the output our query has
been successfully executed let me just
select the records so as you can see uh
other number column has been
successfully deleted and similarly you
can also delete multiple columns as well
all you have to do is just write the
same query and put a comma
and write again the column drop column
keyword here and let's say if I want to
delete the pi number as well so
pan number as well as the UN number here
now so I can use this query here
so let me just execute this on CD output
so our query has been executed let me
just display the records
so as you can see uh the U.N number as
well as the part number has been
successfully uh deleted from the
employee table as well and similarly the
alter statement table statement is also
used to add and drop various constraints
on an existing table like which we have
discussed earlier if you want your
column uh a null value then you can
mention the null as the constraint there
and if you don't want any null values
for your columns then you can use the
not null keyword in your uh alter table
statements so in this way you can use
the
uh alter table statement to perform
various column operations in SQL so that
was all about the SQL column operations
guys where we have discussed about how
to add how to delete and how to update
or modify the existing columns in the
database add the tutorial by
understanding what is SQL join and then
we'll discuss why we use SQL join and
then we'll go through different types of
SQL joints such as sqlena join SQL Auto
join SQL left join and finally SQL right
join so without any further delay let us
dive straight into today's topic so what
is SQL join in relational databases the
information you want to retrieve is
often stored in various different tables
in such scenarios you'll need to join
these tables to view data in a much
better way this is where SQL join comes
into picture SQL joints is widely used
clause in SQL essentially to combine and
retrieve data from two or more tables
based on related columns or you can say
common fields between them now consider
two tables here table one has three
columns ABC and three records let's say
for reference we'll take them as one two
three similarly table 2 also has three
columns BCD and three records three four
five here I have taken a different color
combination to represent values that are
present in various columns now instead
of querying each table every time to
retrieve data I'll simply join these two
tables and this will be the following
result 10 table also make sure when you
are joining two tables it should
compulsorily have a common column here C
is the common field which forms the
basis to join these two tables here
why we use SQL join
flexibility SQL join allows the user to
access and manage records from more than
one table easily let us understand with
an example consider Mercedes-Benz which
is one of the leading car manufacturers
in the world and let's say they want to
access the records of their customers
from the database now in the database
let us take they have various different
kinds of tables such as customer table
order table vehicle table now if they
want to get the vehicle details of so
and so customer XYZ for that they have
to first query the customer table to get
the customer ID now if once if they get
the customer ID they have to query the
order table to get the order ID and
finally with the help of order ID they
can get the vehicle details now as you
can see this is a time taking process
and hectic at the same time now instead
of that I'll just simply join these
tables which will allow the users to
combine rows from two or more tables
based on different types of conditions
in this way you can access and manage
your records easily
data redundancy SQL join allows the user
to maintain data redundancy as much as
low as possible so that we can maintain
the amount of data anomalies that is the
duplicate values that are repeated in
various tables in the database
finally efficiency SQL join executes the
query faster and shows the result much
more quickly because instead of using
various sub queries for each and every
table individually we can just simply
join uh two tables using us a simple
single query
types of SQL joints SQL joints are
broadly classified into four types they
are inner join outer join left join
right join and additionally we also have
cross join which is not that significant
uh in its usage because most of the
times we use the first four joints now
that we have gone through different
types of SQL joints let us discuss each
of them in detail
firstly let us discuss about SQL inner
joint SQL inner join joins two tables
based on a common column and selects
records that have matching values in
these columns now when the condition uh
is applied for these columns the query
checks all the rows of table 1 and table
2. only the rows that satisfy the join
predicate are included in the resultant
table let us now understand the uh
syntax of the SQL inner joint the syntax
is followed as select table one dot
column one table one dot column two
table2. column one and so on from table
1 in a join table 2 on table one dot
column equals to table 2 dot column now
inner join syntax basically Compares
rows of table one with table two to
check if any anything matches based on
the condition provided in the on clause
and when the condition is met it returns
matched arrows in both tables with the
selected columns in the select clause
let us now discuss about the SQL outer
join SQL outer join or else it is called
as SQL full join or full outer join is
used to get all the rows which are
present in both the tables that means it
will return all the records which are
present in either left table that is the
table one or the right table that is
table two even if there are no matching
records present in both the tables let
us now understand the syntax the syntax
remains same that is selectable one dot
column one table one dot column two and
so on up to table 2 dot column 2 from
table 1 full outer join is the keyword
that we use here table 2 on table1 dot
column equals to table two dot column
now here we have to mention the uh the
same or the similar column name in the
uh after the on predicate statement
next we have SQL left join left outer
join also known as left join results in
a table containing all the rows from the
table on the left side of the join that
is the first table and only the rows
that satisfy the joint condition from
the table on the right side of the joint
that is the second table any missing
values uh for the rows from the right
table in the result of the join tables
are represented by null values let's
look at the syntax the syntax is
followed as select column list that is
the column that you want to display in
your table now make sure you maintain
the syntax of the columnist that is the
table name dot column name otherwise it
will throw an error so let me just
repeat the syntax the syntax is Select
column list from table one the keyword
that we use here is left join table 2 on
table1. column equals to table2 dot
column so in this way you can use the
left join to display the records
next finally we have the uh SQL right
join now right join or right outer join
is uh opposite to that of the left outer
join now it follows the same rules as
the left join and the only difference is
that all the rows from the right table
and only the conditions satisfying the
rows from the left table are present in
the resultant table that means it will
return all the rows from the right table
and all the matching records that are
present in the left table the syntax
Remains the Same that is Select column
list that you want to display in your
table from table one right join is the
keyword we use table 2 on table one dot
column equals to table 2 dot column now
to sum up all these different SQL joints
and how they work I've taken a graphical
representation of two different tables
here which will help us visualize the
real time working of SQL joints now
consider table one here which is columns
A and B and Records uh two different
records let's say record zero record one
and similarly we have table 2 which have
columns A and C and two records that is
record zero and record two now if you
apply left join and by the definition of
left join it will only return those
values which will which are present in
the left table and the matching records
that are present in the right table now
here the uh matching value that are
present in both the tables is 0 and the
require values that are present in the
left table is one and if you consider
the right join it will match the request
from both the tables and it will display
the only you know values from the right
table that is the reason it is being
displayed uh the record 0 and the record
two and if you look at the inner join it
will match the values from both the
tables now the common value that is
present in both the tables is record
zero and if you finally look at the
outer join it will return all the values
from both the tables irrespective if
they are matching or not that is the
reason uh all the records that is record
0 record 1 and record two are being
displayed and with that we have come to
the end of today's session that was all
about SQL joints stay tuned uh for more
upcoming videos awaren will execute all
these types of joints in MySQL workbench
using various examples
so what is SQL inner joint using the
inner join the tables are combined on
the basis of a condition also known as
The Joint predicate this condition is
applied on The Columns of both the
tables on either side of the join Clause
the query checks all the rows of table 1
and table 2. now it will display only
those values that satisfy the joint
predicate in the resultant table that
means it finds the matching values or
the uh matching records that are found
in both the tables for example I have a
table a which is records 1 2 3 4 and in
table B I have records three four five
six now if you join these two tables now
the resultant output output will be 3
and 4 because these are only two records
that are present in both the tables that
is the table is matching the common
values that are present in both the
tables let us now understand the syntax
of SQL inner joint the syntax is
followed as select table one dot column
one table one dot column two table two
dot column 2 and so on from table one
inner join is the keyword we have to use
table 2 on table one dot column equals
to table two dot column here after the
join expression we are mentioning The
Columns uh from which we want to match
the both the tables now that we have
understood uh what is SQL in a join let
us jump into MySQL workbench and execute
it with the help of an example
as you can see MySQL workbench has
started and on the left side you can see
the database that is simply code and the
various tables that are present in our
database simply code like we have
customer table Department table employee
table order stable Etc now to perform
the SQL in a join operations I will use
the employee table Department table and
the projects table now let us display
the values that are present in the table
so that we have to use the select
statement or you can directly click on
this table icon here so first let us
display the values present in the
employee table the employee table has
the following Fields such as employee ID
employee name age designation the city
they belong to salary date of joining
and their Department ID next let us
display the values that are present in
the department table the department
table has two fields that is Department
ID and Department name and finally let
us display the values present in the
projects table the project stable has
the project ID employee ID the project
name and the project manager
now let's say we have a query here which
says to retrieve the employee details
and the department they are working in
now before we write a query we have to
check uh for all those tables in which
these informations are present in for
example I can get the employee details
from the employee table such as their
employee ID employee name the
designation salary and so on and also I
can get the Department details from the
Department table now the expected uh
query or the resultant table is based on
these two tables now in order to
retrieve the records from these two
different tables I need to connect them
in other words we have to join these two
tables this is where the inner join
comes into picture with the help of
inner join we can connect these uh two
tables and we can retrieve all those
matching records from those tables now
the following query uh would be for the
inner join as
select mention the column names that you
want to display now I want I will
display the employee ID
so employee
dot employee ID I'll also display the
employee name so employee dot employee
name
I'll also display the uh employee
designation
so I am taking employee.designation
now I'll uh also retrieve the
information from the Department so I'll
have to mention the department table
here as well so Department
dot Department ID
right now the query is continued as from
the table table one that is employee
I'll just write in the next send next
sentence from employee
inner join is the keyword we have to use
here and mention the second table that
is Department
on which is the keyword and mention the
condition on the basis of which you are
connecting these two tables now I am
connecting the employee and the
department table with the hemp with the
help of the department ID so I'll
mention employee Dot
Department ID
equals to
Department
dot Department ID
so let us now execute this statement and
see the output
so as you can clearly see it is
displaying the values of employee ID
employee name the designation and the
department ID as well now as you clear
clearly you can see that the join
condition is specified in the inner join
Clause after the on keyword as the
expression now for each row in the prod
in the employee table the query finds a
corresponding Row in the department
table that has the same matching values
based on which we have mentioned here
that is the department ID now if there
is a match between two rows in both the
tables it returns all those rows that
contains columns that we have specified
for example we have specified employee
ID name designation and the department
that they belong to
so in this way you can use the inner
join to get the requests from both the
tables
also you can get the Department name as
well by uh mentioning the department
names in the uh query the department
name dot department DOT Department name
now this will display uh the records of
the department name that are present in
the department table as well
so as you can see uh there are total of
uh six records and the employee details
and the department names that they are
working in and also if you uh notice
there are only six records that are
present in a resultant table when we
have a total of 20 records that are
present in the employee table that's
because the energy only matches those
records from those columns that are
having matching values from both the
tables and and also the condition that
we have specified uh in our in a joint
statement
similarly let us look at another query
which says to retrieve the employee
details project they are working on and
the project manager assisting them now
for this to get the employee details
again I'll again use the employee table
and to get the details of the uh project
uh name and the project manager's name
I'll use the project table so the
following query would be select e dot
employee ID now here I have taken the
Alias name for the tables that is you
can mention a temporary name for the
tables that you have chosen so for
employee table I'm taking as e and for
projects I am taking SP in order to save
time and uh to save time we'll write in
this way so the query is followed as
select e dot employee ID e dot employee
name p dot project name p dot project
manager from the first table that is
employee
e inner join projects we have taken the
name as p on E dot employee ID is equals
to P dot employee ID which is the common
column from which we get the matching
values from both the tables let us now
execute uh this statement and see the
output
so as you can see we can uh we are able
to retrieve the employee ID employee
name project name that the employee is
working on and the project manager that
uh have been assigned to these employees
and if you notice uh carefully here like
some of the employees who are having
employee ID like thousand and twelve
thousand and thirteen thousand eighteen
sixteen uh there have no project names
assigned to their uh to their names that
this is because even though we have all
the details of employees uh in the
employee table we do not have the data
that that is being stored in the
projects table that is the reason uh
only a limited number of records are
being shown and as per the definition of
inner join it will re fetch only those
records which have matching values from
both the tables
so in this way you can join uh two or
more tables using the inner join
statement and with that we have come to
the end of today's session that was all
about SQL inner joint so if you want to
upskill yourself in the field of data
analytics and become proficient in SQL
and database management then our
postgraduate program in data analytics
in partnership with Purdue University
and in collaboration with IBM can help
you with that this course features
master classes and follows an applied
learning model designed with real life
projects and business case studies which
will help you boost your career so what
are you waiting for enroll now and take
advantage of this amazing opportunity
you can find the course Link in the
description box below in
in part let us just give
this quick what is SQL Auto join the
outer join statement returns all those
records which are present in either the
left table or the right table now for
example if you consider uh the table
here a which has records one two three
four and the table B which has records
three four five six now if you apply the
full outer join to these two tables it
will display all the records that is one
two three and up to 6.
now let us discuss the syntax of SQL
outer join the syntax is followed as
select table one dot column one table
one dot column two table two dot column
one and so on these are basically the
columns that you want to display in your
resultant table from table one full
outer join table 2 on table one dot
column equals to table two dot column
now as far as MySQL concern this syntax
is not applicable now if you're working
on other databases like postview SQL and
Microsoft SQL Server you can apply this
uh syntax but if you're working on MySQL
workbench there is a different syntax
which I'll be discussing in a while so
now that we have understood what is SQL
Auto join let us jump into MySQL
workbench for the execution part
as you can see MySQL workbench has
started and on the home page on the left
side you can view the databases and
tables now I've created uh certain
tables uh time for time being so let me
just display the values that are present
in these tables now in order to execute
the I scale outer join we'll consider
the employee table as well as the
project tables so let me just display
the values present in the employee table
I'll use the select operator to display
those values select start from
employee
so it will display the records of all
those employees having employee ID
employee name is the designation City
salary date of joining and their
Department ID now similarly I'll display
the records of projects let me just take
another tab
I'll use again the select statement to
display the records
start from projects
now I've execute this statement it will
display the project ID employee ID
project name and the project manager
details now let's say if I want to fetch
the details of all the employees from
the employee table and the project
details they are working on from the
projects table I'll have to use the full
join to retrieve information from both
the tables now as discussed earlier the
full outer join keyword is not
applicable to mySQL database so I'll
have to implement a new logic here which
is quite simple as you know the full
outer join is the result of combining
the left and right table so we'll first
use the left join then we'll use the
right join and finally we'll use the
union operator which is used to combine
the resultant set of two or more select
statements and uh and execute it in a
single statement by the way we haven't
executed left and right join yet so stay
tuned for the upcoming videos on both
these joints as well if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free visit
skill up by Sim simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
so the following query would be
let's take another tab again
select
now mention all those column details
that you want to display in your
resultant table so I want to display the
employee ID employee name project name
and the project manager's name as well
so you have to mention the column names
in the format of table name dot column
name so I'm taking the uh Alias name for
the employee table as e so e dot
employee ID comma e dot employee name
now for the projects table I am taking
the Alias name as p
so P Dot
project name
comma
P Dot
project manager's name
from the table that is uh project tables
sorry the first table is employee right
so we'll mention the employee now use
the left join keyword
left join on projects
on now I have to mention the condition
uh on the basis of which you're
connecting these two tables now if you
look at the two tables we have the
employee ID that is present in both the
tables so that will be the common
attribute to specify this condition here
so e Dot
employee ID equals to P dot employee ID
now I'll just copy paste this same
statement
and uh instead of using the left join
I'll use the right join keyword so let's
just replace the left join keyword with
the right join
and I'll mention the union operator
keyword to join these two tables so
that's it guys uh this is how you can uh
use the full outer join in MySQL
workbench now let us just execute this
statement and see the output
so there's a bit of error let me just
check it once
so I forgot to mention the Alias name
here for both the table so that is why
it is throwing an error so as you can
see this is our output and you can
clearly see that the record from both
the tables that is the left table which
is employee and the right table which is
projects are being displayed here now
unlike the inner join which only fetches
those records which have matching values
in both the tables full outer join
retrieves all the values irrespective of
whether they are matching or not for
instance if you look at the employees
having employee IDs here 1 not 1012 1013
1016 and as well as 1018 we have uh
their information present in table one
that is the employee table here but we
do not have their information in the
projects table here and similarly
employees having employee IDs like 1022
2023 and 1024 their information is
present in the projects table but it is
not in present in the first table that
is employee you can see only the
employee details are having their
employees ID up to 2020 are being
displayed in the employee table also if
you notice the resultant table here guys
uh some of the employees like
and uh
nithya have no uh projects assigned to
their name that's why we have null
values in the project name column that's
because though the records are present
in the employees table but their
employees IDs are not present in the
project table that means all these
employees are yet to be assigned a new
project so if the values present in both
the tables that does not match it will
simply just return null values similarly
we can see the other three projects that
are present uh in the table but there is
no sign of employee details here be it
their employee ID or employee name and
it will just simply return the null
values again here because we do not have
the employee information in the first
table employee even though their IDs are
mentioned in the project table and hence
it will only return null values now
suppose this is just a demo table having
around 20 or 25 records but if you
consider a company's database in real
life it will have thousands of Records
in order to access and manage various
database tables and fetch information
from those tables all together it
becomes quite difficult right so this is
why we use full join to connect the
tables and retrieve each and every
information from them and in if any
column has null values they can just
simply update those rows or even delete
them as per the requirement let's just
have a quick recap on what is SQL left
join so SQL left outer join also known
as left join results in a table
containing all the rows from the table
on the left side of the join that is the
first table and only the rows that
satisfy the joint condition from the
table on the right side of the join that
is the second table the missing values
for the rows from the right table in the
resultant table of the join are
represented by null values for example
if you consider here two tables that is
table a and table B which is values 1 2
3 4 in table a and three four five six
in table B now if you apply left join
for both these tables or it will display
only the values from the left table that
is 1 2 and the matching values from the
right table that is 3 4 so the resultant
table will be one two three four
let us now understand the syntax of the
sqlf join statement the syntax is
followed as select column lists these
These are basically the list the columns
that you want to display in a resultant
table from table one left join which is
the keyword we are using here table two
on table one dot column equals to table
two dot column now yeah here you have to
mention the uh a common attribute on the
basis of which you are joining these two
tables so now that we've understood
about SQL left join let us now jump into
MySQL workbench to execute this using
various examples
as you can see MySQL workbench has
started and on the home page on the left
side in the schema section you can view
the databases and the tables that are
present so in this case we have the
database simplicode and various tables
in that such as customer Department
table employee orders and Etc now in
order to execute this uh left join
statement will will be going to use
customer and the order stable statement
tables so let me just display the values
from both these tables for that I'll use
the select Clause select star
from
customer
which is the table name so let us just
execute
so as you can see the customer table has
various Fields such as customer ID
customer name age address and their
phone numbers similarly let us go to
another Tab and display the values that
are present in order statement
select star from the table that is
orders
so let us execute this statement so as
you can see in the output the orders
table has various Fields such as product
ID customer ID product name that is the
product I've purchased quantity the
price of the product and the purchase
date
now let's say if I want to fetch the
details of all the customers and the
product details that they've purchased
I'll have to connect these two tables
that is customer and the orders table to
get the resultant table now for that
I'll use the left join statement so let
me just take another Tab and execute the
statement so the following query would
be select mention the column names that
you want to fetch in your resultant
table so I'm going to take here
Aaliyah's name for both the customer and
the orders table as C and O that's
because uh instead of writing the full
name of the tables each and every time
you can just simply use an alias name
which is a temporary name which will
save time as well so for customer uh
table I'm taking as C so I want to
display the customer ID
so C Dot
customer ID
I want to display the customer name
customers address so C dot address
now from the orders table I want to uh
mention the products name that they've
purchased the quantity price and
purchase date
so we have taken o as the alliance name
for our table so O DOT purchase name
sorry product name
that they have purchased
I also want to display the quantity so o
dot quantity
price as well O DOT price
and the purchase date oh Lord
purchase date
from the table first table that is
customer
mention the Alias name c
left join which is the keyword
on the second table that is orders
o on mention the condition on which you
are joining these two tables so as you
can see we can find the customer ID and
the customer ID in both the customer and
the orders table so we'll mention the
customer ID as the column common
attribute here so C Dot customer ID
equals to
O DOT
customer ID so let us just execute the
statement and see the output
so as you can see it will display the
customer ID customer name address
product name quantity price and purchase
date of the customers in a resultant
table now let us understand what exactly
the left join statement is doing here
firstly the database checks each and
every row of the table and looks for a
match in the right table based on the
related columns now if a match is found
the data from the right table is added
to the corresponding row of the left
table now you can see uh customers
having customer ID
101101012010130 and one zero one three
one four zero we have the details
present in the first table as well as
the second table that is orders so it
will display all those records and then
if there are multiple matches now in
this case we can see a customer name RJ
is having two different Records who has
bought sofa set and a TV so the rows in
the left table are duplicated here that
is the records are repeated in the
resultant table in order uh to include
all the records from the right table
so now for all the
columns that you have fetched from the
right table that is orders which is not
satisfying the join conditions then the
values present in the columns will be
resultant as null that means if there is
no matching value found from the right
table it'll simply retain the row from
the left table and inserts null into the
corresponding Columns of the right table
now let me just explain this now if you
see here the customer uh customers like
others and pranay who are having details
in the first table that is a customer
table but they do not have their details
in the Pro orders table so there is no
sign of any
their customer ID in the order table
that's why we do not have their details
present in the uh resultant table so it
will just show the null values here
so basically left join is a combination
of inner join we can say because it just
checks the matching values from both the
tables first and then it will check for
any additional or extra values that are
left out from the left table that is the
table one now you might have a question
that when to use and why to use the left
join like there are times when you want
to keep rows from the first table that
don't have any corresponding records in
the second table now if you in this case
if you consider our example we might
want to see information about all the
customers in a resultant table even if
they didn't place any orders so in that
case we'll use the left join which will
be used to combine data from two tables
so that all the rows from the left table
are included in the resultant set even
if there is no matching value from the
right table
SQL right outer join also known as the
right join works the opposite way to
that of left outer join it follows the
same rule as the left join and the only
difference is that all the rows from the
right table and only the condition
satisfying rows from the left table are
present in the resultant table
so basically the right join returns all
the records from the right table and
only the matching records from the left
table are satisfying the condition for
example let's say we have two tables
table a and table B and when the Left
Right join is applied to the two tables
it would give all the records from the
table B and only the matching records
from the table a that is table one
let us now look at the syntax of SQL
right joint the syntax is same and it is
followed as select table one dot column
one table one dot column two table two
dot column one and so on these are
basically the columns that you want to
display in your resultant table from
table one right join is the keyword we
use here table two on table one dot
column equals to table 2 dot column
now that we've understood what is SQL
right join let us jump into MySQL
workbench for the execution part
choose from over 300 in-demand skills
and get access to 1 000 Plus hours of
video content for free visit scale up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
so MySQL workbench has started and on
the left side you can view the database
simply code which has various tables
such as customer Department employee
orders now for time being I've already
created and inserted values into all
these tables and to in order to execute
the SQL right join we are going to use
the customer table and the orders table
so let me just display the values that
are present in these tables for that I
am going to use this select statement
select star
from the customer table
foreign so as you can see the customer
table has a various Fields such as
customer ID customer name their age
their address and the phone number
similarly let us just retrieve the
request from the orders table as well
select star
from orders table
so the orders table has of various
columns such as product ID customer ID
product name that they've purchased
quantity price of the product and the
purchase date now if I want to join
these two tables I am going to use the
right join statement so the following
query would be
select now I am going to use a layers
name for both these tables for customer
table I'm going to take as C and for
orders table I'm going to take as o now
I want to display the columns from the
customer table uh only so the tables are
the columns are customer name I want to
display their address as well so mention
the column names customer name
C dot address
now from order stable I am going to
display the product name that they've
purchased quantity price and purchase
date
so O DOT
product name
comma O DOT
quantity
comma o dot price
and finally o dot purchase date
from the table one that is customer
mention the keyword right join
mention the second table name that is
orders
on mention the condition on which you
are joining these two tables now now as
you can see we have customer ID as well
as the customer ID present in both the
tables customers and orders so we'll be
taking the customer ID here as the
common column on C Dot customer ID
equals to O DOT
customer ID
let us now execute the statement and see
the output
so there is just an error let me check
okay I didn't mention the Alias name
here so mention the Alias name for both
the tables
I guess it will display now
so as you can see this is our resultant
table which uh basically displays the
various columns customer name their
address product name quantity price and
purchase date let us now understand what
exactly the right join is performing
here now basically the right join Clause
starts selecting the data from the right
table and matches it with the rows from
the left table the right join returns a
resultant table that includes all the
rows in the right table whether or not
they are having matching rows from the
left table now if a row in the right
table does not have any matching rows
from the left table The Columns of the
left table in the resultant set will
have null values now clearly the SQL
statement would return all the rows from
the orders table here as you can see we
have all the details like AC TV phone
cooker car sofa set and phone bike Etc
in our orders table so it it is
basically retrieving all the data from
the right table and only those rows from
the customer table where the join
condition is being satisfied now it will
only display the matching values here
because can you as you can see we have
customer
id101101012010130 so basically we have
one total six records and we have
them in the resultant table as well now
if you consider the resultant table here
it is showing null values for some of
the customer names and address because
though we have the product names
mentioned in the orders table here for
example the product name car sofa set
bike and the customer IDs are one zero
one four zero one zero one six zero and
one zero one nine zero but we do not
have their uh details present in the
customer table and that is the reason we
that it is showing is null here
so in this way you can use the SQL right
join statement now you might have a
doubt that when to use and why to use
the right drawing statement again it
will depend on your own requirement for
instance if you want to keep the records
from the second table that do not have
any corresponding records from the first
table in that case we will use the right
join also another point to be noted here
that the table that you have mentioned
to the right side of the right join
keyword that is we have taken here
orders right so it will give the highest
priority to this table and it will
display all the records from the orders
table here even if they do not have any
matching values similarly just take
another scenario here I'm just
interchanging the tables here like the
first table I'm taking is orders and the
second table I'm taking as customers so
when we execute this statement it will
display the records from all the records
from the customer table that is the
first table and even if they do not have
the matching values it will just display
the null values here that's because now
if you consider other
we have their details uh in the employee
in the customer table but we do not have
their information present in the orders
table and that's the reason we can see
that only their details are present but
they do not have the orders details that
we are present here
so in this way you can use the right SQL
join statement as well so with that we
have come to the end of session guys
that was all about the SQL right join
statement understanding what exactly are
SQL keys and then we'll understand why
we use SQL keys and finally we'll go
through some different types of keys
that are used in SQL so without any
further Ado let's dive straight into
today's topic on SQL keys
so what are keys in SQL SQL Keys plays
an important role in relational
databases it is used for identifying
unique rows from table a key is a subset
of columns in a table that allows a road
to be uniquely identified so a key can
be more than just a column and every Row
in the table will have a unique value
for the key or a unique combination of
values if the key consists of more than
just one column
now as you know databases are used to
store massive amounts of information
which is stored across multiple tables
now each table might be having more than
thousands of Records or rows now
needless to say there will be many
duplicate rows with redundant
information so how do we deal with that
now how do we manage these records that
are storing only unique data now for
that we might need a combination of one
or more columns in the database table to
uniquely identify a row in a database
so in that case we use the SQL Keys now
SQL Keys creates constraints that can be
used to enforce data Integrity in SQL
now as you know a database must adhere
to certain properties to maintain
integrity and quality of the data that
is storing keys and constraints are
rules that Define what data values are
allowed in certain data columns there
are an important database concept as
well as for SQL and are part of database
schema definition defining keys and
constraints is part of database design
process and ensures that data within a
database is reliable and maintains
integrity
let us now understand why we use SQL
Keys SQL Keys identify each record
separately and uniquely now a key is
used in the definition of various kinds
of Integrity constraints and a table in
a database represents a collection of
Records or events for a particular
relation now since there are thousands
and thousands of such records some of
which may be duplicated now in order to
identify these records uniquely and
separately we need SQL keys
allows user to establish and identify a
relationship between the tables as well
and finally SQL Keys access or manages
the store data quickly and smoothly
now that we have understood what SQL
keys are and why we use them let us now
discuss some of the various types of
keys in SQL SQL keys are broadly
classified into various types such as
primary key Super Key candidate key
alternate key composite key foreign key
now let us discuss each and every type
of key in detail with an example
firstly let us look at what exactly is
primary key
the primary key is one of the most
important and commonly used SQL keys in
the databases the primary key is in SQL
is a single or a group of fields or
columns that can uniquely identify a row
in a dipl putting it simply it is a
column that accepts unique values for
each row therefore whenever you use the
insert into command to insert new values
in a table the value for a primary key
column or columns need to be unique now
primary key advantages is mainly it
uniquely identifies each row of a table
also it gets a unique index for each
primary key column that helps with
faster access
now there are properties which are
helpful of SQL primary key they are it
enforces uniqueness by not accepting any
duplicate values and a primary key also
uniquely identifies each field and can
take only one primary key for a table
now primary key column cannot accept
null values as well
let us consider an example here consider
student table which is having various
Fields such as student ID role number
name class section is an address now if
you look at the table clearly student ID
can be taken as a primary key here also
you can take the roll number but since
we are taking the records of all the
students in a school that's why we are
taking the student ID as the primary key
now if you take the records of the
students for a particular class then you
can take the roll number as a primary
key as well
let us now understand the syntax of
primary key Now to create a new table
with a column defined as a primary key
you can use the keyword primary key at
the end of the definition of that column
and the syntax is create table table
name and within the parenthesis mention
the column names and its column types
and finally mention the primary key
inside the brackets
so for example if I want to create a
table which is having ID last name first
name and age in that I am going to use
the primary key here as ID so in this
way you can use the primary key in SQL
next let us discuss about the candidate
key a candidate key is defined as set of
one or more columns that can identify or
record uniquely in a table so basically
candidate key is a Super Key with no
repeated attributes by the way uh we'll
discuss about the super key in a while
uh the primary key should be selected
from all the candidate keys and every
table must have at least a single
candidate key and a table can have
multiple candidate keys but only a
single primary key now candid key
shouldn't have redundant attribute that
means it should not have any duplicate
values in the table now unlike primary
key the attributes of candidate key can
contain null values and as discussed a
table can have more than one candidate
keys and it is also called as the
minimal Super Key guys that's because we
select a candidate key from a set of
super Keys such that the selected
candidate key is the minimum attribute
required to uniquely identify the rows
in a table so let us understand this
with an example consider the students
table here which is having various
columns such as student ID role number
name age address and contact now as you
know we can take the student ID as the
primary key and with that we can take
the rule number as well as the contact
of the students as the candidate key
here because all these three columns
alone can uniquely satisfy the condition
of the candidate key here so in this way
we can use the candidate keys in SQ
next let us discuss about alternate key
in SQL
alternate key are subset of candidate
keys that can also uniquely identify
tuples in a table which are not chosen
as primary key for example consider the
employee table here which has columns
employee ID employee name job department
number pan number other number and uan
now if you look at the table uh The
Columns that can uniquely identify each
and every record are basically employee
ID pan number other number and UA number
now since we have taken the employee ID
as a primary key and the rest of all the
columns that are not chosen as a primary
key are considered to be alternate keys
so in this case we can take the pan
number other number UN number as our
alternate keys next let us discuss about
the super key in SQL super key is
another important key that is used
day-to-day usage and SQL databases a
Super Key or a simple key is a
combination of all possible attributes
which can use uniquely identify the row
or tuples in a table that means that a
Super Key may have some extra attributes
which isn't necessary for uniquely
identifying the rows in the table
a Super Key is a in SQL is a superset of
primary key candidate key and Alternate
key that means basically it is a
combination of all the keys such as
primary candidate and Alternate Keys as
discussed super key will have additional
attributes that are not needed for any
unique identification and finally super
keys with the least number of attributes
form the candidate keys
so let us take an example again consider
the employee table here and if you look
at the possible keys that will be for
super keys are employee ID part number
employee ID other number employee ID uan
number other number pan number uan other
number uan employee ID pan number as
well as un and finally pan number other
number and uan
now all the above keys are able to
uniquely identify each row so each of
these Keys is a Super Key now again in
this example we have like more than uh
six Super keys but all of them cannot
become a candidate key here only those
super Keys would become a candidate key
which have no redundant attribute for
example uh if you take employee ID pan
number this key cannot be considered as
a candidate key because uh when we take
this subset of this key we get two
attributes that is employee ID as well
as the pan number now each of these
attributes is basically a candidate key
so it is a minimal super key but hence
this key is not a candidate key
and finally let us discuss about the
foreign key in SQL a foreign key is a
column or combination of columns that is
used to establish and force a link
between the data in two tables to
control the data that can be stored in
the foreign key table in a foreign key
reference a link is created between two
tables when the column or columns hold
the primary key value for one table and
the reference by the column or columns
in other table now this column becomes a
foreign key in the second table the
table with the foreign key is known as
the child table and the table with the
primary key is known as the referenced
or parent table
now as foreign key has bought the
referential Integrity in SQL uh which
means that
it requires that a foreign key must have
a matching primary key or it must be
null this constraint is specified
between two tables that is parent and
child and it maintains the
correspondence between the rows in these
tables it means that the reference from
a row in one table to another table must
be valid now the foreign key uh helps in
maintaining the data Integrity of the
table and allows easy navigation between
two instances or attributes it is also
used in SQL to make the database data
consistent and it is also used for the
prevention of any action that may result
in destruction of relation between these
two tables
let us understand this with an example
now consider two tables here employee
and Department the employee table has
employee ID employee name job department
number pan number other number and UN
number and the department table has
employee ID and the department name now
clearly the employee ID which is the
primary key in the first table employee
is acting as a cross reference for the
Department table that is uh the employee
ID acts as the foreign key here for the
Department table
so in this way you can use the foreign
key in SQL
and similarly we have some other types
of keys in SQL which are not that
significant in its usage the first one
being is unique key a unique key same as
a primary key with the difference being
the existence of one null value in a
table field or a row for example
consider a student table having student
ID roll number and its name now for some
reasons if the student is leaving the
school then his roll number might be
deleted although his student ID will be
preserved for further assistance so
since there is a null value in roll
number it can be considered as a unique
key and student ID can be considered as
a primary key similarly we have
composite key a composite key is a
combination of two or more attributes
that can together uh can uniquely
identify a tuple in a table
and that brings us to the end of today's
session uh that was all about uh the SQL
keys so let us just quickly recap what
we have discussed uh the different types
of keys so to summarize this I've
created a table here employee ID
employee name other passport department
ID which is the table one that is
employee table and we have Department
idea and Department columns in the
second table that is Department table
now you are clearly employee ID is the
primary key since it uniquely identifies
each and every record in the table and
employee ID are the number password can
be taken as candidate keys because they
are set of more than one primary keys
since though so they can be considered
as the candidate key here now alternate
Keys which are other than the primary
key that is employee ID so I am taking
other card and passport as the alternate
Keys here now the combination of all
these keys that such as primary key
candidate key alternate key forms are
super key now I am taking the passport
as the unique sense and not but everyone
has a passport to their name so I'm
taking the passport attribute here as
the unique key and finally the foreign
case the department ID as it points uh
to the reference to the second table
that is Department table
so in this way you can use the SQL Keys
accordingly firstly let us go through
the agenda for today's session we'll
start the tutorial by understanding what
is aggregate function and then we'll go
through different types of aggregate
functions in SQL and finally we'll
discuss the syntax of each and every
aggregate function and Implement its
execution part in the myx MySQL
workbench
so without any further delay let's dive
straight into today's topic
now we have Akash who is basically from
a non-technical background and wants to
upskill his career as a business analyst
and for that his learning SQL now while
learning these SQL concept Concepts is
unable to understand the aggregate
functions in SQL so he turns up to his
friend Rohan for help now Rohan is
already a certified data analyst starts
explaining him about the aggregate
functions in SQL the aggregate functions
in SQL are used to perform calculations
on multiple rows of single column and
returns a single value
now in SQL each query delivers filtered
results of groups of values as well as
field values now SQL has these aggregate
functions that can be used to summarize
these enormous amount of data that is
stored in the table now for an entire
group or table this function can
generate a single value they work with
groups of rows and returns all the
possible results based on these fields
or columns
these aggregate functions are basically
used with the group by and having clause
in the select statement the group by
Clause basically divides the result set
into groups of values and aggregate
functions returns a single value for
each groups that means the group by
basically identifies all their records
that are present in a particular field
or a column and combines them into a
single set now that we have understood
what are aggregate functions let us go
through the various aggregate functions
that are present in SQL now in SQL there
are broadly five types of aggregate
functions they are count some average
Max and minimum let us discuss about
them in detail firstly let us discuss
about the count function
the SQL count function Returns the
number of rows in a table satisfying the
criteria specified in the where Clause
it sets the number of rows or non-null
column values only let us look at the
syntax the syntax is followed as select
count which is the keyword column name
from table name where condition Group by
column and order by column
next let us discuss about the sum
function in SQL
the sum function Returns the total
summation of the value of a specified
column value sum performs only on
numeric columns only so
sum does not consider null values it has
optional arguments like all distinct all
keyword is used to take all the values
in the specified column now if you
specify distinct keyword it will remove
all the duplicate values or the
Redundant values
let's look at the syntax the syntax is
followed as select sum column name from
table name where condition Group by
column and order by column
next let us look at the average function
the SQL average function calculates the
average value of columns of numeric
types it Returns the average of all null
values and the syntax is similar to that
of count as well as the sum instead of
the count and the sum keyword you have
to replace it with the average keyword
and the syntax is followed as select
average column name from table name
where condition you can also specify the
group by and the order by function as
per your requirement here as well
next we have the max function the SQL
Max function is used to find the maximum
value or highest value of a certain
column or expression this function is
useful to determine the largest of all
the selected values of a column and the
syntax remain the same which is Select
Max is the keyword we use here column
name from table name you can specify the
condition as per your requirement using
the where clause and you can use the
group by function as well
and finally that brings us to the
minimum function which is opposite to
that of Maximum function and the
aggregate SQL minimum function is used
to find the minimum value or the lowest
value of a column or an expression this
function is useful to determine the
smallest of all the selected values of a
particular column or a field
and the syntax Remains the Same Again
instead of instead of Max you have to
use the minimum keyword here and the
syntax is followed as select minimum
column name from table name where
condition and group by condition as well
so now that we've understood all these
different types of aggregate functions
let us jump into MySQL workbench for
execution part
as you can see MySQL workbench has
started and on the home page to the left
side we have the simply code database
which has various tables such as
customer Department employee orders and
Etc now as far as the SQL aggregate
functions are concerned we are going to
use the restaurant orders table here so
let me just display the records that are
present in this table for that I am
going to use the select statement select
star from table name that is restaurant
orders
so as you can see the table has various
columns such as order ID order date item
name quantity and price by the way guys
I have taken this data set from kaggle
so if you want to work on the same data
set we'll leave the link in the
description below so you make sure you
check this out
so firstly let us discuss about the
count
function here so if I want to count the
total number of records that are present
in this table I'll use the count
statement here as the following query
would be
select
count
use the asterisk operator because we
want to display all the records
from the table that is restaurant orders
so let me just execute the statement and
see the output
so as you can see there are total of
three not seven records that are present
in this table let's take another example
now let's say if I want to find the
total customers that are present in this
table so for that I'll use the order ID
as the reference that's because now if
you consider uh for any customer we'll
get a different order ready when he
places an order right so for that I'll
use the order ID so the following query
would be select count
now I'll use the distinct operator here
so that will have the unique values
order ID
from the table that is restaurant orders
so let me just execute the statement and
we'll see the output
so as you can see there are total of 48
customers that are present in the table
who have placed orders on various items
now let's take another example let's say
if I want to find the total number of
orders of each item that is present in
the table then the following query would
be
select
take the column name that is
item name
now I want to count all the records that
are present so I'm taking the count
operator
from table name that is restaurant
orders
now I want to group all the identical
values that are present for each of the
orders that are present so I'll take the
group by
function here
item name
and similarly I'm using order by so that
I want to display the orders in their
alphabetical order
so item name
so let me just execute the statement and
see the output
so as you can see it will display the
total number of records that are present
on each of the item that the order has
been placed now we have a total of uh
let's say four records of aloo gobi and
eight records of Bombay Aloo and so on
and Etc
so let me just uh verify this statement
and see uh if the condition that is
executed is true or not so I'll use the
select statement select star
from restaurant
orders
where
item name
equals to I will see the records of
Bombay Aloo so let me just copy this
field
and see the output
so as you can see uh we have a total of
one two three four five six seven and
eight so clearly we have a total of
eight records that means our count
function has been successfully executed
so in this way you can use the count
function in SQL
you can also use the where condition
here as per your requirement let's say
if I want to display the list of all the
items and the total number of orders of
each and every item whose price is less
than three dollars and for that I'll use
the where statement so these syntax
remains same I will just use the where
condition here where price of the item
mentioned the column is less than three
dollars so let's just execute the
statement and see the output so it will
display all those records who's having
uh the price less than three dollars so
let's just verify for example uh we'll
take the garlic naan here as our example
and let's see if this condition is
satisfied or not
let me just copy this field and I'll
paste it here
and let us execute the statement and see
the output
so as you can see that we had four
records of garlic naan and it is being
presented here and its price is also
2.95 Which is less than 3.
let us not discuss about the minimum as
well as the maximum function in uh
aggregate functions now let us take an
example for that let's say if I want to
find those items which is having the
least amount of price so for that the
following query would be select minimum
is the keyword and within the brackets
mention the column that is price
from the table that is restaurant orders
so let us select the statement and see
the output so as you can see the minimum
price of the item in the table is 0.5 so
let us take another example here now
let's say if I want to find all those
items in the restaurant order table
which is having the cheapest price so
for that I'll use the query as select
display the item name
and its price
from the table that is restaurant orders
where
price equals to now we'll write a sub
query here using uh the minimum
statement
where select
minimum
price
from the table that is
restaurant orders
so let me just execute the statement and
see the output
so it will display all the records uh in
the restaurant order table and the item
details which is having the least or the
cheapest price for example mango chutney
onion Chutney mint sauce and red sauce
is having the least price that is 0.5
now we can see there are duplicate
values in our resultant stable so I'll
just take the distinct keyword so that
it will terminate all the Redundant
values in the resultant table
so let me just execute the statement
so as you can see these are the four
items which is having the least price
now similarly you can find the maximum
uh
price of the order or the item that is
present in the restaurant order table
for that I'll use the max keyword here
so let me just execute the statement and
see the output so these are the three
items which is having the maximum are
the highest price in our table that is
thundericking prawn Masala King Brown
balti and King prawn which is having the
price 12.95 which is the highest so in
this way you can use the maximum and the
minimum function to find out the highest
and the lowest value that is present in
your table
let us now discuss about the sum
function in aggregate functions now
basically the sum function is used to
calculate the total sum of all the
records that are present in a particular
column let's take an example let's say
if I want to find the total amount that
the restaurant has received on a single
day then the following query would be
select sum
now if you look at the orders table we
have different quantities for each item
right so the price will uh so the price
will be basically price into quantity
that will be the total value of the item
so I'll take select some price into
quantity from table that is restaurant
orders
foreign
capital in the record so we'll take as Q
as capital so let me just execute the
statement and see the output
so there's a spelling mistake here
let me just correct that and let us see
the output now
so as you can see it will show me the uh
total sum of all the items that were
placed on that particular day and the
value is
1689.9 dollars now you can name the
column as per your wish as well so I'll
just take it as uh total amount
so in this way you can use the uh sum
function as well let us now discuss
about the average function
now average function is also similar to
that of some but basically it calculates
the average of all the items or the
records that are present in the table
now let's say if I want to find the
average price of all the items that are
present in our restaurant orders table
then our following query would be select
average
price
from restaurant table
so let us see the output
so as you can see the average price of
all the items that are present is 5.04
dollars so in this way you can use the
average function as well
let's take another scenario for average
price where we'll use the where
condition let's say if I want to display
all those items that are having price
above the average price of all the items
that are present in the table then the
following query would be select I want
to display the item name so I'll take
the item name column
their price
from the table that is restaurant where
price is greater than I'll write a sub
query select average
price
from the table that is restaurant orders
so let me just execute the statement and
see the output
so basically these are all the items
which are having price more than uh our
average price that we have calculated
earlier that is 5.09 so in this way you
can use the wire condition as well up as
per your requirement but there's a point
to be noted here that the average and a
sum function basically calculates only
those fields which is having numerical
values whereas the count uh minimum and
maximum function can uh calculate the
values of various data types such as
character string as well as the
numerical values so if you want to
upskill yourself in the field of data
analytics and become proficient in SQL
and database management then our
postgraduate program in data analytics
in partnership with Purdue University
and in collaboration with IBM can help
you with that this course features
master classes and follows an applied
learning model designed with real life
projects and business case studies which
will help you boost your career so what
are you waiting for enroll now and take
advantage of this amazing opportunity
you can find the course Link in the
description box below by understanding
what is SQL Group by statement and see
why we use Group by clause and then
we'll understand what is SQL order by
statement and why we use order by clause
and next we'll see some key differences
between these two statements and finally
we'll understand the syntax and look
into the execution part in MySQL
workbench
so what is SQL Group by now SQL allows
the user to store more than one type and
up to almost 30 types of data types in
as many columns as required so sometimes
it becomes difficult to find similar
data in these columns now Group by in
SQL helps us club together all these
identical rows present in The Columns of
a data Group by statement is used to
group together any rows of a column with
the same value stored in them on a
function specified in this statement
basically Group by Clause is used to
group the rows which matching values
using the specified condition now
generally we use this group by Clause
with aggregate functions such as count
Max minimums maximum and average by the
way guys uh if you want to know more
about the aggregate functions make sure
to check out our previous video on
introduction to aggregate functions
where we have discussed about these in
detail
now uh the SQL Group by statement uses
the split apply combined technique here
now the different groups are split with
their values and then an aggregate
function is applied to these values of
these groups and finally the values are
combined into a single row now if you
consider this example here we have two
columns and we have three different
items uh a b c having different values
now you can see a has two values four
seven one three
and C has nine four now when we split
this and apply the sum aggregate
function which results in the arithmetic
sum of all these row values as you can
see now a has values four and seven now
when I apply this sum it becomes 11 and
b 1 3 it becomes 4 and C 9 4 it becomes
13. so it will display all these
identical rows having matching values
and into a resultant set so in this way
you can use the SQL Group by
let us now understand the syntax of SQL
Group by statement the syntax is
followed as select column one column two
up to a number of columns from table
name where condition Group by column
name now the group by statement lets the
database system user know that we wish
to group the same value rows of the
column specified in the statements
column names parameter and you can also
use there is an optional where clause
which can be used to specify any
condition According to which the row are
to be selected
next let us understand what is SQL order
by statement the order by clause in SQL
sorts the data of a column in the SQL
database it helps us sort the column in
both ascending as well as the descending
order the ASC keyword helps us sort in
ascending order while the desc keyword
sorts in descending order and if no
keyword is specified in which we have to
sort the records in the column it will
take the default value the order by
Clause sorts the required in ascending
order by default if it not mention any
specific keyword that is AAC or DAC
now the order by Clause can only be for
select statements and the order by
keyword is used to sort the resulting
table in either ascending order b or
descending order based on the column
specified in the statements column name
now another important thing to be noted
here is that the order by statement
always appear after the group by
statement and is applied to the group of
rows form now let us look at the syntax
the syntax is followed as select column
1 column 2 from table name where
condition which is optional as per your
requirement Group by column list order
by column name and you can mention the
AC or desc keyword as per your need
now that we have understood about both
of these statements let us now
understand the differences between Group
by and order by now Group by statement
is used to group the rows that have the
same value whereas the order by is used
to arrange the data obtained in the
resultant table of a query in sorted
form
now the groupa is always used before the
order by clause in the select statement
whereas the all order by statement is
used after the group by clause in the
select statement
now in group by statement the attribute
under the aggregate function cannot be
in group by Clause whereas in order by
the attribute under aggregate function
can be in order by Clause that means if
the group a clause contains an attribute
that is not under select clause or if it
is under select Clause but under
aggregate function then the query
becomes invalid and it throws an
exception hence we can say the group by
Clause is always used in collaboration
with the select Clause now in group by
it is mandatory to use one of the
aggregate functions like count sum
average minimum maximum Etc whereas in
order by statement it is not compulsory
and mandatory to use the aggregate
functions and finally the group by
Clause controls the presentation of rows
or tuples whereas the order by statement
controls the presentation of columns
that means the group is only concerned
with the values of identical rows in the
resultant set whereas the order by
statement uh basically arranges the data
in the columns in either ascending or
descending form now that we have
understood about both these uh skill
statements let us jump into MySQL
workbench for execution part choose from
over 300 in-demand skills and get access
to 1 000 Plus hours of video content for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
so as you can see MySQL workbench has
started now in order to execute the
group and order by statement we'll
consider the data set of an employee
which have already downloaded from
Google so let me just import the data
set into the MySQL workbench for that
all you have to do is just go to the
tables Tab and right click on it and
you'll find table data import wizard
click on that now it will ask to import
the location from where you have said so
I have saved my file in desktop so I'm
just selecting the file
now once you select the file click the
next button here now it will ask if uh
to name the table whether to use
existing table or to create a new table
so I'm just taking a new table here
employees one
and click on next
it will display all the columns that are
present in that CSV file so just click
on next
click on next and it will start to
prepare the import now depending upon
the number of Records present in the
data set it will take bit of time so
don't worry now as you can see our data
set has been successfully imported so
we'll click on next again
so uh it is showing that fault Name
Records have been important successfully
so let me just refresh the schema here
and as you can see employees one uh has
been shown in the table section so let
me just display the records that are
present in these uh tables for that I'm
using the select statement select star
from employees
one
so as you can see our employees one
table has employee ID first name last
name email phone number hiring date job
ID salary manager ID and finally
Department ID
now firstly let us discuss about the
group by Clause uh now let's say if I
want to fetch the total employees in all
the Departments from the employees one
table then the following query would be
select now I can take the employer ID to
display the total number of employees
because each and every every employee
has a different employee ID to their
name so select
foreign
employee ID
as total
comma
I want to display their Department ID as
well
so I'm taking Department ID
from employees table
employee one
Group by
now we want to group all their
Department ID right so I'm taking
Department ID
so let me just execute the statement and
see the output
okay
the table name is wrong here so let me
just correct it
so as you can see it will display the
total employees that are present in each
and every department now if you look at
the department ID column uh we have the
values in a random way now in order to
display in a systematic and a proper way
this is where we use the order by
statement so we can sort the department
ID values in the ascending or descending
manner as per your as per a requirement
so I want to display an ascending order
so order by
Department ID
let us execute the statement and see the
output so as you can now see that the
department ID are being displayed any in
the ascending manner that is 10 20 30 40
50 and so on up to 110. so in this way
you can use the group by an order by
statements
so that was all about the group and
order by a statement so this is just to
give a quick uh review on how these two
statement works now if you want to learn
more about the order by statement make
sure to check out our rescale order by
video on our channel uh where we have
discussed about it more in depth and
with more examples as well
and also you might have a doubt that
when to use Group by and when to use the
order by statement now if you want to
form the group of uh the set of records
are the identical columns having values
in them then you must use Group by
clause and in case you want to arrange
the data of a single or a multiple
column uh with variable different
conditions or in that case you have to
use the order by to sort the data in
ascending or descending order we are
going to learn about between operator
and SQL now SQL provides us with many
such tools that help in retrieving
useful information from all kinds of
data sometimes we need to retrieve only
a particular range of values from all
the values of a tables column for
example to retrieve the information
about all the employees of a company
born in a particular decade or a year or
let's say to find the salaries of all
those employees in a particular range
you need a tool for that now SQL between
operator helps in performing these
activities and is an integral part of
this query language so in today's
session we are going to discuss about
the between operator in detail with its
syntax and execution in MySQL workbench
so without any further Ado let's get
started with today's topic but before we
begin if you're new to the channel and
haven't subscribed already consider
getting subscribed to our Channel simply
code to stay updated with all the latest
Technologies and hit that Bell icon to
never miss an update from us so without
any further delay let us jump straight
into today's topic so as you can see
MySQL workbench has started and before
getting into the execution but let us
just quickly understand what is between
operator and SQL now the SQL between
operator is used to test whether an
expression is within a range of values
or not his operator is inclusive so it
includes only the start and end values
of the range and the values can be
textual numerical type or date type now
between operator can be used with select
insert update as well as the delete
command so to get a clear picture of how
this operator works let us get into the
syntax of it now the syntax is followed
as select column names from table name
where column name between range start
and range ends so the columns to be
retrieved are specified after the select
statement and that and the table The
Columns are being retrieved from the
specified is the in is in the from
statement and then we have the between
operator which is used in the where
Clause the column we want to apply the
range condition on is specified with the
column name parameter and the starting
value of the range of values is
specified in the range start parameter
and the ending value in the range and
parameter so now that we've understood
how exactly the between operator works
let us get into some examples and
understand its execution part so let us
take an example to understand the SQL
between operator so I am taking the new
employees uh as the example here so let
me just display the values for that I'm
using the select operator select start
from new employees let us execute the
statement so the new employees table has
various columns such as Employer ID
first name last name email phone number
hiring date job ID salary manager ID
Department ID
that's it so all right now we'll take a
simple example uh to understand the
between operator so let's say if you
want to retrieve the ID and name of the
employees with IDs in the range let's
say now we have IDs up to range like 198
200 2.1 so let us take uh the range
between 110 and let's say 170 then
reduce the following query as select
employee ID
comma first name
from table that is new employees
use the word condition
where employee ID
between is the keyword
and 170.
so let's execute this and we'll see the
output
so as you can see it will display the
records of all those employees whose
employee ID lies between the range that
is 110 and 170. now if any employee
who's having their employee ideas 110
even their values are also included in
the resultant set and similarly if any
employee has 170 in their as their
employee ID even their data will be in
the result and set now in the table we
do not have any employee who's having
the employee ideas 170 so we do not have
the information now so in this case it
will only display only the details of
all those employees who's having the
employee ID range in 110 and 1 7 and 1 7
well moving ahead let us take next
another example now we can use the order
by statement also to sort the result
based on some columns now let's say if
you uh want to retrieve the details of
all those employees with salary ranging
from 35 000 to let's say 75 000 and in
order to sort this result based on the
salary we'll use the following query as
select in order to display all the
details so I'm using the star operator
select starts from new employee
where
salary
between 35 000
and let us take let's say 55 000.
right and I'll use the order by
salary
so that it will display the values of
all their salaries in the ascending
order so let us execute and we'll see
the output
so as you can see there are only uh
five employees in our new employees
table uh for example run scale Ladwig
who's working as a clerk he's having
salary 36 000 which is in the bracket of
thirty five thousand and fifty five
thousand similarly we have Diana
Lawrence whose salary 42 000 similarly
we have Jennifer Valen who salary is 44
000 and so on so in general we use the
between operator to find the range of
values like for example we are finding
the salary range right so in a similar
way we can use the between operator
to find the range between
two given values of a particular column
now similarly we can use the not
operator with between as well now we can
also use the not operator with the
between operator to select the values
that do not belong to that specified
range now instead of using between if I
mention the not between keyword here
it'll basically display all those
records of employees whose salary is not
in the ring of 35 000 and 55 000. now it
will display the records of all those
employees like if you take Hermann bear
whose salary is 10 000 which is not in
the bracket or in the range of 35 000
and 55 000. similarly it will display
the records of all those employees whose
salary is not in between that range
which is 35
000 and 55 000. in this way you can use
the not between keyword as well which
will exclude uh the results that are not
in the given range now you can use the
uh between operator with the date values
as well now when using the between with
dates or the date time values we need to
remember to enclose the date in single
inverted commas as otherwise the credit
will return a syntax error so let us
take an example here let's say if I want
to retrieve the details of all those
employees whose hiring date is in
between let's say 2000 and 2007. now as
you can see our hiring date is between
like 2005 2004
2002 and similarly Etc right so in that
in that case I want to display all those
employee details whose hiring date was
in between 2000s and 2007. so in that
case the following query would be select
starts from new employees again which
will display all the records where
higher date
between mention the inverted commas so
I'll take from 1st January
and
31st December
2007.
right so let us execute this statement
and we'll see the output
so it will display me the records of all
those employees who have their hiring
date in between this range which is
January 1st 2000 and 31st December 2007.
so in this way you can use the between
operator with the date values as well
right moving ahead uh now we can use the
between operator with the text values as
well between operator can also be used
with the character data types uh like
for example while using any text values
we need to remember to again enclose the
data in single inverted commas otherwise
it will return a syntax error so let us
take an example here let's say uh we
want to retrieve all the employee
details and along with their names
belonging to a range from let's say
alphabets A and J that means we want the
details of all those employees whose
name is in between the first letter that
is a and the letter J in that case the
following query would be select star
from new employees
where I'm taking first name
right first name
between
letter a and letter j
and close them in the inverted commas
and we'll see the output now
so let us also order
we'll use the order by statement so that
will have in ascending order
I think there is a no need for that so
we'll just directly uh
execute this so as you can see it will
display the records of all those
employees uh whose name is in the range
with starting letter a and the starting
letter J now you can see Donald
O'Connell whose first name starts with d
right so it is in the range of a and j
it will it lies between a and j and
similarly we have Hermann we have
Alexander and David guy himero Etc
so in this way you can use the between
operator to find the values in a
particular range which have only text
data types and that brings us to the end
of today's session guys that was a quick
tutorial on how to use the between
operator in SQL if you remember all the
SQL between operator rules and syntaxes
you can easily customize your queries to
retrieve the type of information that
you want this tool along with other SQL
tools enables us to write different
kinds of essential queries now this
between operator is generally used to
find the values within a certain range
for example you can find the salaries of
employees within a certain brackets you
can also find the marks of the students
in a particular range and similarly you
can find the details of the products
which lie in a certain range so in all
these cases you can use the between
operator as per requirement so now that
you know about the between operator it
is time for you to start using the
between operator along with other SQL
commands Clauses and operators to query
your database tables in today's session
we'll have a detailed comparison between
the where and having Clause now let's
say you are navigating through a huge
database and you wish to display only
certain records that satisfy a
particular condition now carrying this
search process is extremely difficult
and is also time taking now in order to
save time and make your search easier we
use the where and having clause which is
used to explicitly filter out only those
records that meet the condition
specified by the user more on that soon
but before we get started if you are new
to the channel and haven't subscribed
yet consider getting subscribed to our
Channel simply code to stay updated with
all the latest tech content and hit that
Bell icon to never miss an update from
us so without any further Ado let's get
started with today's topic firstly let
us discuss the agenda for today's
session we'll start the tutorial by
understanding what is SQL where clause
and then we'll discuss what is SQL
having clause and then we'll have a
detail in comparison between where and
having plus and finally we look at the
syntax and implement the execution part
in MySQL workbench so let us now dive
into today's topic
so firstly we'll discuss what is wire
Clause the SQL where Clause is used to
specify a condition while fetching the
data from more than one table or by
joining with multiple tables if the
given condition is satisfied then only
it returns a specific value from the
table now we can use the wire Clause to
filter the records and fetch only the
necessary requests from a database the
where Clause is not only used in the
select statement but it is also used in
the update delete
Etc
let us now understand the syntax the
syntax is simple and is followed as
select column 1 column two so on from
table name where condition
let us understand with an example
consider the employee table here which
is having various columns such as ID
name age City and salary now let's say
if I want to uh find the employee who is
having the maximum salary in this table
and for that I'll write a query stating
select star from employee where salary
is greater than 50 000. now if you
implement this query it will basically
show those records which is having
salary more than 50 000. now if you look
into the table Kumar whose ID is 1175 is
having 52 600 which is greater than 50
000. so in this way where basically uh
meets the condition that is set by the
user
let us know understand what is having
clause in SQL
the having classes generally used along
with the group by clause and having
Clauses used to filter the results
obtained by the group by Clause based on
some specific condition having Clause is
quite similar to that of where Clause as
both are used to filter records in SQL
but where Clause cannot be used with the
aggregate functions like count Max sum
and Etc which is why having Clause is
needed and that is the reason we use the
having clause
let us now understand the syntax the
syntax is also similar you have to
mention the having keyword here instead
of where and the syntax is followed as
select column one column two from table
name Group by column 1 column two so on
having and mentioned the condition now
group a clause is used to arrange the
data into groups and having Clause is
used in the column operations and it
basically group all the identical data
and gives you the condition that is
specified by the U
let us understand this with an example
again consider the same employee table
here which is having ID name HCT and
salary now
as we know we have to use uh aggregate
functions so I'm using the average
function here and since the having plus
also uses a group by
um so that is the reason I'm also using
the group by
now let's say if I want to find the
average salary of all the employees from
different cities then the following
query would be select City average
salary from employee Group by city now
when I perform this query the this will
be the following output where it will
show the resultant set of all the cities
and their average salary now we have New
Delhi that is being repeated wise which
is two records and we have ghaziabad
which is two records now New Delhi has
two requests which is having service 36
000 and 38 000. now if you consider the
average it is basically 37 000 and
similarly for gaziabad we have three
records which have salaries for 6500 for
2652 600. now when you calculate the
average it is showing us forty seven
thousand two thirty three
now now that you have applied this now
let us have the having condition here
now let's say if I want to find the
average salary of all those employees
from different cities who is having
average salary greater than 40 000.
now in this case if I implement this
query this will be the following output
as you can see both ghaziabad and Noida
has the average salary more than 40 000
that is forty seven thousand two thirty
three and forty eight thousand so in
this way you can use the SQL having
Clause as well
let us now look at the differences
between these two Clauses that is a
skill wear and having loss
now SQL where Clause basically filters
the individual rows in the table based
on the specific condition whereas the
having Clause filters groups instead of
one row at a time
now as discussed earlier where Clauses
can be used with select update delete
statement whereas the having uh Clause
can be used only with the select
statement
now where comes before group a which
means that where plus filters rows
performing aggregate calculations and
having comes after Guru by which means
the having plus filters Rose after
performing aggregate uh calculations so
consequently having is or slower than
where in terms of complexity and
efficiency as well now as discussed
earlier where class cannot contain
aggregate functions and having plus can
contain aggregate functions such as
count sum average
Etc
now SQL wire is considered as a
pre-filter because it performs the row
operations first and having Clause is
considered as a post filter because it
performs the column operations after
grouping the data
so now that we have understood about
these both types of SQL Clauses let us
jump into MySQL workbench for the
execution part if getting your learning
started is half the battle what if you
could do that for free visit skillup by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
so as you can see MySQL workbench has
started and on the left side you can
view the simply code database which is
having different tables such as customer
Department employee employees one and
Etc now to perform the where and having
Clause statements we'll use the
employees once uh table so let me just
display the records present in that
table so I'll use the select operator
select star from employee
employee one table
click on the execute Button as you can
see the employees one table has various
columns such as employee ID first name
last name of the employee their email ID
phone numbers hiring date job ID salary
manager ID and Department ID
so firstly let us discuss about the
where uh clause or basically where
condition so let's say if you want to
fix the records of all those employees
from these employees one table whose
salary is let's say less than 5000 and
they belong to Department 30.
so in that case the following query
would be
select
star
from employees
table one
where
salary is less than five thousand
now I'm using the and operator which is
basically a logical operator so whenever
you're performing the where condition
you can use the logical operators and
comparison operators logical operators
such as and or between Etc and the
comparison operators like less than
equal to less than greater than equals
to
Etc
so I'm using the and operator here and
Department ID
is equals to 30.
so let me execute this statement and see
the output
so as you can see there are total of
four employees whose salary is less than
50 000 and they belong to the Department
30.
now you can also as discussed earlier
you can also perform the update
operations uh using the where uh
Clause as well now let's say if I want
to update the salary of uh employee who
is having employed in 116 as let's say
10 000 then the query would be update
table name that is employee one
set
salary equals to 10 000.
where
employee ID
is equals to uh let's say 160.
an employee name is Shelly baida so I'm
just uh
taking that example so let me just
execute this query so as you can see our
query has been successfully executed so
let me just verify whether it is
executed or not so I'll use the select
statement select star from
employee one
required
employee ID
equals to 160.
so let me run this query and we'll see
the output so as you can see the
employee uh Shelley baida who's having
employee ID 116 and their salary has
been changed into 10 000 here
successfully so in this way you can use
the uh where Clause as well
you can also use the where clause for
delete also now let's say if I want to
delete uh the details of the employees
who's having employee ideas 120 let's
say then I'll use the delete statement
delete from
employee one
where
employee ID is equals to 120.
so let me just execute this query
yeah
so as you can see our query has been
successfully executed here and the
details of the employee who's having
employed is 127 has been deleted
successfully so in this way you can use
the where Clause to perform various
operations such as select update delete
Etc using comparison and logical
operators let us now understand about
the having clause for that let me take
an example let's say if you want to
display the records of all those
employees present in different
departments and whose average salary is
uh greater than let's say a 5000. so in
that case the following query would be
select
now I want to display the department ID
so I'm taking the department ID column
average salary
from employees
one
now as you know while using the uh
having Clause we have to use the group
by uh statement as well so I'll Group by
all the department IDs since we have
multiple Department IDs present in the
table
Department ID
having
average salary
greater than 5000.
five thousand dollars okay let me just
display the output
so our query has been successfully
executed and as you can see here it is
displaying all the different departments
uh and their average salaries as well
here now I can use different aggregate
functions here as well if I want to
count uh the number of employees in each
department I can take the con function
so let me just use it count employee ID
which will basically count all the total
employees in the different departments
so let me just execute this statement
so as you can see it will display the
count of all the employees that are
present in different departments and
having average salary more than 50 000.
so in this way you can use the having uh
Clause as well now we can also combine
both the where condition as well as the
uh having condition as well
now we can combine the where and having
plus together in a select query in this
case the where Clause is used first to
filter individual rows and then the rows
are then grouped to perform the
aggregate calculations and finally the
having Clause is used to filter the
grouped data that is the identical
groups that are having the same values
now as discussed earlier uh
we have to use the where condition
before the group I so I am just taking
the wire Clause before the group by and
let's say if I want to display only
those uh departments that are having
more than 80.
as their Department ID so Department
ID
greater than 80.
so let me just display
so as you can see it will display only
those records where the department ID is
more than 80 that is 1900 and 110 and
the details of all the employees whose
average salary is more than 500. now I
can also use the order by uh statement
here in order to mention all these
records in a systematic manner that is
an ascending or descending order so
order by
Department ID
so let us execute this query so as you
can see it will showcase the department
ID values and the ascending order that
is 1900 and 110. so in this way you can
use the having uh Clause as well in SQL
and with that we have reached the end of
this SQL Basics training course we hope
you found this video informative and
interesting if you have any further
questions please feel free to let us
know in the comments and we'll have it
answered for you at the earliest until
next time thank you for watching stay
safe keep learning and get ahead
if you like this video subscribe to the
simply learned YouTube channel and click
here to watch similar videos turn it up
and get certified click here
foreign